hello
okay okay uh would everybody please take
their seats we're ready to go ahead and
we're a little past 9:30 according to
the wall clock there um I'd like to
welcome everybody to the next round here
we have going on um with the uh bills
which are coming forward uh in House
Education we're going to be trying to
move through these in a timely manner we
have 107 bills coming to us of which 23
are early bills and close to 50 of them
have fiscal notes on them so we have our
task in front of us it is 6:30 and the
first bill which we have in the doca
today is uh 10 or 10008
1,8 and that bill is relative to the the
authority of the commissioner of the
Department of Education to Grant
extensions for filing of school
expenditure reports and I'd like to
welcome representative Sally fellows uh
to present the
bill good morning I filed this bill at
the request of the Department of
Education but I also worked at the
Department of Education for over 30
years so I understand what this bill is
attempting to do and and I um completely
agree that it's a good idea uh it seems
um a little
unnecessary to identify only the
commissioner is a person who could Grant
these extensions because they come up
fairly frequently and he would probably
pass it on to the next person who is
likely to speak so I um completely
support this Bill thank you very much uh
representative are there any questions
we do have following Sally um uh the
Department of Education here to speak to
this as well for technical support good
thank you have a question for uh you you
have one question here uh thank you
representative um I was just wondering
if this um uh section um with the change
applies to uh all
reports uh I think not hold on
Mark get that one okay I'll let Mark
answer okay thank
you so thank you very much uh I'd like
to welcome Mark
magnoli I hope I said your last name
properly Mark I've had struggled with
that ever since I've known you in the
LBA that's okay Mark magello Department
of Education Bureau of school Finance um
so yeah uh the department worked with
representative fellows to uh craft this
bill um it's just two changes really um
it's the this relates to the doe2 which
is the financial report that districts
and Charter Schools complete um those
reports are due September 1st um we so
we start um uh notifying all the
districts and charter schools that the
reports are due September 1st uh with
districts there is uh more pressure to
get those reports in timely because Dr
can't set tax rate until those reports
are in and complete and valid and
reviewed by us um so about um uh I have
some data here I um I don't have data
for when they come in but um the
Department of Education is able to
approve about half of all doe 25s by the
close of September 30th um so most of
the saus are getting their doe 25s in
timely um and and and moving through the
process pretty quickly um but sometimes
in SAU uh
uh for whatever reason needs to extend
the deadline of when they think they can
get the doe2 in there could be a lot of
reasons one of the main reasons is
turnover um within the saus um if it's a
new ba coming in um they might need more
assistance and help um getting their
do25 in and so the way the process works
is um uh anyone who wants an extension
on the do25 we generally Grant it um
then we get later into the later months
October November we are going to start
telling districts that were not going to
be granting doe 25s extensions and they
really just need to get them in um if
they want to have a tax rate which they
do um so this is mostly administrative
um we don't um we don't have to uh we
can usually Grant these extensions um
because districts are incentivized to
get their reports in so they can have
tax rates um but instead of just going
through the commissioner and kind of
bugging bugging the commissioner it'
just be easier if you had the authority
to uh use a design um um the one change
we that's for granting extensions um the
one change we did not uh uh the
authority still is fully within the
commissioner not a designate is if um
the commissioner wants to withhold State
funding um he doesn't have the authority
to delegate that to anyone um this is
only delegating the authority to Grant
the extensions um which we Grant um out
don't the number but half of half of
districts need an extension um so
instead of having it come through him
off his office I can maybe do it a
little bit more
efficiently and I'm open for questions
thank you very much represent
Damon thank you Mr chair good morning
thank you for being here so two
questions you just indicated that about
50% of the districts don't submit in
timely manner it seems unlikely that 50%
of them have turnover in business
administrators so why else is it delayed
so
it's it's the doe2 sets you up for a
successful tax rat set season so there's
a bunch of documents that they districts
need to finalize and there's a lot of
pieces to the puzzle and so a lot of
districts we we try to tell them to not
sit on the doe2 if you don't know what
your fund balance is going to be just
give us a doe 25 and we'll review it but
that's usually the final pieces of the
puzzle for setting tax rates is their
fund balance so how much they're going
to give back to the taxpayers what their
revenues are going to be in the future
um those are the two main pieces um and
so some districts like some districts
have really uh well-run SAU offices they
can close their books they don't believe
they have any material errors in their
financial statements but they just their
preference is to hold on to it for a
little bit longer um we tell them you
don't need to do that um but we we but
we're happy if we're getting half of
them in in September it keeps us busy so
we don't normally hound them um but some
of them do want a little bit more time
um and like I said I'll grant them 30
days days in September um I'm going to
stop I sto giving them time as we get
into October they really need to get
them in um so it's not the end of the
world if if they're getting it into us
the end of September or the 1st of
October um and some districts have that
preference to just have a little bit
more time with their financials um just
so they can set up all their documents
queued up for tax rate setting season
are there further questions from the
committee
quickly so the if I'm understanding you
correct ly the longest extension is 30
days correct oh uh no so uh the
extension the extension can only go 30
days but then there's second extensions
and third extensions so some districts
need a second extension um and a third
extension and so in those second
extension cases it's probably
something's going on that's more
dramatic like rap uh extreme turnover in
their SAU um sometimes they could have a
cyber security attack which would make
them difficult for them to close out
their fun Financial reports um so the
second extensions are kind of the more
um uh extreme circumstances um that
would cause them to delay getting their
doe 25s
in I have one more and that's
it one more thank you very much Mr
chair is there
any
uh any waiting or any preference to
districts to Cooperative districts where
many towns tax rates are contingent on
that information being sent that is a
good that is a good question that is
where
so kind of the the stick we have is we
can stop we can we can withhold their
state funding um to get um them to speed
up their process um we it's a kind of a
balancing act in a sense that we want
the do doe 25s to be coming in so we
don't have to review all 178 within a
short window um so we tell the districts
get them in so you don't overwhelm us
then they're getting pressure from the
towns so Cooperative districts tend to
get the most pressure because they have
the most amount of towns that are
dependent on so those ones are we always
prioritize Cooperative when a
Cooperative do25 gets in that's the
first one we do because we know that
there's not just one town that's going
to be angry it's going to be multiple
towns um and so naturally we don't need
to withhold State funding or punish them
because the towns people are going to
punish them by emailing Dr emailing me
emailing the SAU you know yeah yeah so
so naturally this process kind of
resolves itself um but we like to have
the authority to withhold State funding
if we feel like it's not resolving
itself um and we use this extension
process um to get a status of what's
going on and um with in that situation
when um when a District's really behind
we make sure that they're we tell them
to contact your towns because your towns
especially in the Cooperative need to
know what's going
on thank you represent luno
thank you very much Mr chair thank you
very much Mr mangel for joining us this
morning um you mentioned that the uh
that the commissioner May from time to
time withhold State funding and I'm just
wondering where that Authority comes
from uh comes from this RSA uh so it's
um not in this bill there's I think
three SE three sections of the bill um
the third one is withholding State
funding um that's not being amended here
so that Authority is with the
commissioner and he he has the authority
to withhold State funding for a doe2 not
being completed fantastic thank
you any further
questions thank you very much thank you
Sally represent fellows I'd like to just
add something just I just like to add
that from a historical perspective that
deadline has been in place for a really
long time and you know if you go
backed back to the early
1990s this the doe 25s were less complex
because you didn't have the issue with
the fund balance and also now they have
to do some reporting of expenditures at
the school level which they never had to
do before so just just to let you know I
don't think it's because you know the
business operations have been laxed I
think that part of it is that it's more
complex what they have to do thank you
with that we will close the hearing on
10008 and enter into the hearing for
10009 and I'd like to welcome back
representative
fellow thank you um I I think you
probably well not the people from the
cities but people from the towns I think
you understand what's in the um
the annual report of the Town one of the
things it tells you about is how um the
warrant it shows you all the warrant
articles and what the vote was on the
warrant articles for the prior year so
the Department of Education used to
collect those this goes like way way
back probably before I was even born and
um once in a while and they were stored
in the office that I worked in um
computer and statistical Services way
back in the 1980s and 90s and we would
keep them and maybe twice a year
somebody from the Department of
Education would come down and they would
want to look at those primarily the
warrant articles to see what was voted
on uh could be part of the budget or
could be something else and so now um
Revenue Administration keeps the that
information and also a lot of it is just
online you know you could just go and
get somebody a school district's annual
report so it's not that they don't need
to be available and they will still be
available but the Department of
Education doesn't need to keep
them thank you are there further
questions of the
representative thank you very
much welcome again
mark
so as representative fellows uh
discussed uh this report there's a
report um there's a an RSA that requires
um uh towns to send their Town report to
the Department of Education commissioner
um so this is a law that's valid and
still on the books um I get a couple of
these mailed to me each year and so I
don't really have the authority to say
stop mailing them to me I don't need
them um the internet exists um so if you
were to enact this bill um next time
someone sends me a town report I would
just try to say you don't need to do
that save money on paper um so and as
representative fellow said uh we don't
need these reports um we can access all
the information using the dr's uh
Municipal portal where are you storing
the old reports so we have like at 25
Hall Street uh the our new building we
have a lot of bookcases so I kind of
just put it in a bookcase but probably
could throw also throw it away I don't
know um so yeah I guess it makes it look
like we have more books in our
bookcases further
questions thank you very
much are there any other folks want to
speak to
one9 these are really technical requests
from the Department of
Education thank you yes thank you very
much when we close that that hearing we
got a few minutes into the next now
because we are yeah we we have a few
minutes before the next one
starts um I'll ask the question to the
full committee here and then I'll ask
the your ranking um representative
representative luno is there anybody has
any objections to either one8 or one9 if
there's no objections and we feel these
are as a good move forward on these two
bills we can exec it right now both of
them and get it off our
plate and and just to clarify executive
OTP yes exactly
right so so I'll make a not hearing that
from anybody here I'll make the motion
and then I'll let representa Runo luno
make the one on the other Bill uh I make
a motion OTP on one8 Mr chair I think we
need to go into executive session first
well okay we're entering exec session so
I'll I'll second
that thank you any discussion not see
any let Madam clerk will take the vote
on
one8 Vice chairman cordelli
yes representative leus yes
representative
Ford not here okay uh representative
Belcher yes representative dry
yes representative Noble yes I excuse
me I call if they're not here because
usually in exact sessions we're all here
so I don't call he's absent so just just
call yeah technically what do I do no
just skip over them they're not
present representative Noble
yes representative
Pell yes representative cor yes
representative
Miler oh I'm sorry okay not used to this
uh representative Tanner yes
representative luno
yes representative wock
yes representative Hall yes
representative bbon yes representative
cascaden yes representative Damon
yes 14 yay Zer
nay so the motion for one8 we've
approved that bill with an not to pass
we go on consent consent anybody here
objecting to consent representative Luna
recognize you for a motion on uh one9 I
move House Bill 10009 ought to pass I'll
second
that do you care to speak to your motion
represent luno no I think it was covered
earlier thank you and I don't care to
speak to it either so mam clerk just
when you're ready we're
ready Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes
representative
pure yes representative dry yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative celo yes
representative cor
Tanner
yes representative luno yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative Alon
yes representative cascaden yes
representative
Damon yes 14 yay zero
Nays so the motion OTP passes uh all
right with
consent hearing that fine we'll put that
on consent wouldn't it be nice if they
were all this easy huh huh boy it would
be
wonderful okay we're g we got a a few
moments here to
um break before the uh next bill but
what I want to do is take take a few
minutes here to discuss where we're
going and how we're going to accomplish
some of the things this year um due to
the fact that we have so many bills I'm
going to allow the the sponsors the
prime sponsor of a bill more latitude in
in presenting time than the ones that
are following as
co-sponsors and I'm going to ask and
depending upon the bill the time we've
allocated and the number of people that
are are requesting to speak on it we
most likely will set time limits I'm not
going to set a General time limit for
you know three minutes for every Bill
I'm going to wait and see what we got on
each bill and then set the time limit
when the prime sponsor comes up and
following the prime sponsor we will have
time limits um we also have tried to
schedule these bills so bills that have
like topics for for example higher
education I've communicated with the
community college system the university
system of New Hampshire and all bills
that are are dealing with higher
education we're trying to address them
on the same day so folks from Durham or
Keane or Plymouth or from White Mountain
Community College Etc uh can be here at
one time and not have to make many trips
throughout the course of the
month we also have 23 early bills those
bills have to be out of this committee
heard and EXA by February
15th so that really does put some
pressure on us seeing that those bills
all have Financial notes and there will
be much discussion on them so we're
going to try to get them done as quick
as possible here as quickly as possible
and so we can get that can be in
compliance with the rules that we have
set as a house um there's also a another
set of bills which are dealing deal with
financing or the budget uh adequacy uh
formula and I've set those up this week
on one day and then there will be and
that's on
Wednesday and then on Thursday I've
already assigned a subcommittee to work
on those bills and uh they will be meet
the subcommittee be meeting often
there'll the subcommittee is open to the
public we will be taking technical
support on that those bills
and and and then trying to make a
recommendation back and making a
recommendation not trying making a
recommendation back to the whole
committee here membership on that uh
special subcommittee will involve six
members from this committee right here
two members from finance and two members
from Ways and
Means the people from Ways and Means and
finance will not be voting on the final
result seeing this is a subcommittee of
the education committee but they will
have discussion be treated as members
during the time we are work doing work
as a
subcommittee and I'm not going to
announce those names at this time seeing
that we don't have all those names yet
done by the the for ways and from Ways
and Means and finance those appointments
are being made by the speaker and the
minority leader uh representa Wilhelm so
um when I get word from them as who
their representatives are going to be on
this we're going to have total of five
Republicans and five Democrats on that
subcommittee so that that's that one
right there there will be times this
year got a minute here left that I know
you're going to be out testifying for
bills in fact there were several bills
that came up in Senate education last
Friday when we were in or Thursday when
we were in session and that really I
think perturbed a lot of people here
seeing we couldn't break loose to
testify on those bills and those were
critical bills and so um we know that
those bills are also go bills are going
to go on in other committees here while
we're discussing bills in this this
also so please if you have to get up and
leave just let us know where you're
going or you might even ask somebody on
the other committee you're going to let
us know when there time for us to you
know present our our position that will
help so that you'll be able to stay here
as long as you can if they can text you
a message saying okay we're open now to
you know people in the hearing process
will will go there so also lastly if um
you have to be out for some reason on
this committee for a personal need a
medical issue or or an obligation and
you can't make it that given day I'm not
going to get too bent out of shape over
that we you can see we have several
people absent today um that's okay we
won't be taking you know we will be
executing bills only when there's
agreement like we had just now or when
they're noted in the calendar just know
when it's noted in the calendar then you
cannot accept the bill prior to that
noted date so that's how we want to work
so if you have to take some time off
we're going to be meeting at least three
days a week possibly four then when the
sessions in place and we also try to set
some session days up if we don't have a
whole lot of bills so we're acting in
the morning in session or the afternoon
in session we can use the other half of
the day for hearings here in the
committee and Fridays I'm trying to
leave off uh however for uh many of you
we know that on Fridays that's when all
the other commissions and committees are
meeting and so some of us will be here
five days a week for for several months
so it's it makes it difficult so with
that any comments or input because we're
ready now to go ahead it is
10:00 and we do have a b schedule for
10:00 and so I'd like to open up this
hearing for HB
1014 this is relative to the
registration of high school students to
vote
so okay it looks like we're good
representative pager here
Welcome to our
committee thank you Mr chairman thank
you members of the committee I will be
uh brief it's a pretty um modest bill um
with couple points I'll I'll make on it
I have written testimony coming coming
around um really this does two this
arose out of conversations after we
passed the house passed this um Civics
requirements last session uh
conversations with constituents and
students about what place uh voter
registration might have in that
conversation uh by way of background we
passed a number of Provisions
emphasizing the importance of civics in
schools um so this bill largely um
arises out of that there two operative
Provisions really one is um requiring
schools to inform students about the uh
procedures and process of voting and um
where and how to uh file uh voter
registration it's a pretty modest um
proposal it's it's I think naturally
nested in the Civics education
requirements uh which speak to um now
requiring opportunities for uh Civic
engagement political particip or not uh
civic
participation um
unfortunately
um so so so part of this I hope will
improve on a good law and make it better
um you know voter registration uh in New
Hampshire among eight eligible 18y olds
18 18y olds is pretty low it's around
15.6% we know that um that's an
unfortunate number especially in a place
like New Hampshire where we have a first
of the nation primary and we pride
ourselves on Civic and political
engagement um part of the uh thinking is
that U you know one of one of the
outcomes I guess if we think about uh
Civic engagement and involvement with uh
the processes rates of voter
participation so that's why that's an
alarmingly low rate I could probably
point to numerous studies that have done
that have been done about um how there's
sort of a virtuous cycle that happens
when people participate in the political
Pro process in terms of Civic engagement
that become more active in nonprofits
and Civic Community groups all those
good things there's sort of this
virtuous cycle registration is is one of
those things that for an 18-year-old or
many people can be um a hurdle and so it
seems uh in the view of of some folks
and myself included um that high schools
and our Civics uh conversations will be
an important part to leverage that and
improve that voter participation rate
it's not a Panacea it doesn't solve the
problem at all but completely but it's a
a a tool and part of this um I mentioned
earlier that there's you know a number
of studies about the virtues the low
voter registration rights and
participation but I will point to the
fact that two former Supreme Court
Justices OK Conor and our New
Hampshire's own Justice sutor have made
a career out of in a good way out of uh
a post bench experience of emphasizing
civic's education and making voter
uh participation part of that so um I I
think we would be in good company to
sort of embrace that as and they placed
more more specifically schools as uh a
place where that that can occur so I
think we'd be in good company following
some of their
recommendations um the bill is
intentionally open in its language in
terms of how schools might go about this
in conversations with folks around the
state there are different uh approaches
going on right now it's not terribly
standardized um so this allows in my
view um schools the ability to approach
the problem in creative ways that are
teachers and Educators and
administrators know better than I do uh
they know uh what works in schools and
with their kids and communities and um
they may come up with creative ways to
approach this issue given given the
language uh that's there two other
points I hope maybe and then I'll stop
um
the we as you may recall two years ago
we this this Builds on an existing
framework that already exists in rsas
and by that I mean right now um students
with disabilities as part of their
special education program um are
afforded an opportunity where
appropriate to um register to vote with
with assistance and so this bill extends
the that um opportunity if you will uh
to um all all the general regular
student population so it's building on
something that's that's already in the
in the rsas and one and and talking with
clerks and my and I don't I don't speak
for that Association but a number of
them are very supportive Town clerks are
supportive of any effort that will
reduce um same day registration same day
kind of chaos if you will a good chaos
of people trying to vote but people at
the polls and that sort of thing that
can go on when folks are um you know
long long lines anything that can reduce
that in my view I think again I don't
speak for that asso but conversations
have been looked at and I think this
will do that obviously again it's not a
huge number uh but it is it is one um
one one point to to emphasize um and I I
said two points and I'll leave with one
and that's um as a former fifth grade
teacher way back in in the day I humbly
think that this is one of those examples
where we all know learning by doing is
probably one of the
most one way to maximize any learning
Enterprise right when we're actually
doing the event and or or doing
constructing the learning this is I
think giving an opportunity for schools
to not just talk about the rights and
responsibilities of a civically engaged
person to vote uh but also give that
opportunity to them to actually begin
that process and engage and have that
real
meaningful experience of of of being
part of the of the whole process so um
with that I'm happy to take take
questions thank you very much
representative P I'll have one question
first uh in the last session in in
previous sessions before that uh we've
had much discussion regarding Civics
we've had much discussion regarding
social
studies and we've also been told that
often times social studies and Civics
are put in the backseat of the car have
you done any research here in regard to
we see the 16% of 18-y olds are
registered to vote have you done any
research going back when social studies
was given more emphasis that there was
more of the 18-year-old bracket that was
registering to vote is there been is is
this a trend that's going down or did
you do any historical backback research
yeah that's a good question and I'll be
frank in that I I don't know
historically what the voter what those
rates have been um My Hope and to your
point your broader point about neglect
in terms of civics and social uh studies
and things like that that obviously has
been going on I don't know there may be
someone who can testified behind me that
can speak to those um the contributing
factor something like this might have to
either keeping rates high or improving
them but I don't know historically
someone may on the committee thank very
thank you other other representative
cordelli uh thank you thank you
representative um I believe I heard you
mention that um this uh registration
information was going on now so if
that's the case why do we need this bill
yeah that's a good question I don't know
that it's going on in a Statewide basis
my understand even in um um some of the
communities that are near me and in mine
that it's somewhat um sporadic it might
be um we are in a primary season now so
there's more attention which is a great
opportunity uh for folks to sort of
um gravitate toward the idea of voting
and partic but in non-election years uh
in less popular election years when we
don't have the primary it's probably not
um as standardized if you will or as
across the board so I think what this
would do is ensure that every
18-year-old when you you turn 18 in high
school whether it's a primary year or
not whether you live in exitor or
wherever you're going to have that that
opportunity to do
that you have a follow yeah thank you
thank you just following up on your last
comment there
um it is the requirement now that the
State Board of educ education provide
election law information to every High
School teacher to distribute to their
students so isn't part of this a
duplication of what's going on
already um if you could point me to the
RS is that in the rsas the okay it's
okay it adds to that in the sense that
it would also provide uh assistance and
and filling it out and filing it and it
goes a little bit further uh than that
no we're going to let somebody else uh
representative
dry thank you Mr chairman thank you for
coming in uh as a former fifth grade
teacher are you aware of the kids
Governor program in the
state enough to be dangerous with that
knowledge yes follow up um are you aware
that tomorrow morning at 10 o'clock
there'll be 300 fifth graders in rep
Hall to watch the inauguration of a
program that's been going on for quite a
while so does that not say that it's the
this is isn't this the idea of a
creative Hands-On by you know learning
by doing program that you're looking for
that's already actually taking effect
without being
mandated well I think um I think this
the Civics
um I'm blanking on the group that I
believe H where this the the governor's
program is housed the student Governor
program is housed uh puts that on I I
think that it's certainly the example is
certainly one where you know students we
have every uh uh fourth grader come you
know to to the to rep's Hall experience
the state house which is a wonderful
anybody who's been there it's just it's
just one of my favorite things of this
job um it's a great experience so yeah I
think those are those are examples of
where we've been able to leverage things
um you know respectfully it might be
slightly different in the sense
that um from fifth grade to when you
become 18 and and engage there might be
a lag in terms of of the connection um
uh and and sort of maybe even making
feel feeling like okay you have this
sort of abstract notion I guess of the
Reps hall and then there's the work
which is the you know voting and
registering and things like that which
become a little bit more um
you know experiential at that age so
this might be a uh you know what this
bill might do is ensure that every
18-year-old has that same experience
that you're describing um and and make
sure that uh it continues along along
the way so it's sort of a maybe it's a
natural Continuum of that experience of
going to the Govern 300 kids here or
going to rep's Hall and then maybe folks
teachers would be reminded reminded
their students of when they visited
rep's Hall uh uh you know this is kind
of where you get to decide who gets to
sit here or you get to run and and that
sort of thing so I think it could be a
natural extension across the board thank
you representative beler and then
representative Woodcock yeah thank you
Mr chair and if I may I do have two but
I'll ask for a followup uh thank you for
being here um so generally accepting
certain disabilities we recognize that
are reasonable to accommodate typically
the institutions of the US and of New
Hampshire are set up for people freely
use but they're not typically brought
directly to the people I think that's
often seen as a form of fairness so my
question is if we were to bring voter
registration in the high schools do you
think we should also bring it to other
institutions such as the National Guard
hospitals police Fire EMS even to
people's private
homes so I don't necessarily think that
we're bringing the clerk to the school
that's an idea that's suggested there um
it's it's it's alerting students to the
registration process and assisting them
where where it might be need and and my
understanding is that um you know this
does happen uh both at the school level
but also at some of the institutions you
described U I think I want to say uh um
uh various places where clerks in
different towns and it differs town by
Town um where clerks have actually been
requested to go not necessarily schools
and they go um So based on their work
capacity and the decisions that they
make at that level thank you if I may
brief brief number two uh second
question so the casting of a vote is
generally considered an ultimate
expression of free speech um of course
Free Speech contains both the right to
speak it also contains the right to
remain
silent so should we not therefore have
concerns given the fallibility of people
of government meddling in this process
and the possible coercion or compulsion
to this
speech so so you know you you make a
good point that you know Free Speech
means the right to not say anything as
well or not participate that's an
exercise that we protect as we should um
and I think a couple of points at least
with relation to this bill is um it's
pretty clear that this isn't part of a
assignment or graded if a student wants
to exercise that right to say I'm not
going to participate by registering or
voting or whatever um and you then that
has to be
respected and I think that
um the
risk I I think this is where if you will
for lack of a better term the market
would if if if on the outside chance
that that's that that someone would
attempt to compel
someone to to register to vote in a
certain
way my belief is that the risk of that
in terms of exposure is is pretty high
and would be pretty
quickly um addressed
so I think it's a low chance that if if
close to zero and um yeah so I take your
point I think it's a
fundamental right under our constitution
if if you want to express your vote by
not voting or then that's your right um
and I think I'm pretty confident
in the system as it stands now in terms
of schools that if someone was to
abridge that right that it would be
called out pretty quickly and someone
will probably lose their job in my view
thank you representative Woodcock thank
you chairman good morning how you doing
good to see uh I appreciate the bill I I
do have a question uh just one comment
in the past the schools I have been in
have done this voluntarily uh on a
regular basis so my question is there is
there anything that you're aware of
maybe the Year may be aware of it either
that would preclude any public schools
or child schools any schools in New
Hampshire from doing this now without
this
bill I I I don't think anything would
preclude them from doing it what sort of
two things I'd say to that if I may and
one is
um I I think we would ree as elected
officials in the importance of voting as
a as a right and representative bel's
point just talked about that I think in
some ways um so I think given the
elevated right that we're talking
about um it probably requires in my view
some standardization some ability so
that's it's not in the ad hoc I mean I
know in the high school in my town you
know this year they're they're talking
about doing it only because of the
primary and so some 18-year-old who left
last year didn't didn't have it and and
that my view is fundamentally unfair
whether it's an exor or Conway or
wherever um uh so so so no and I think
this is one of those things we you know
there's nothing prohibiting a school
from offering quilting um but there's a
difference between quilting and voting
in my view in terms of what the what we
want to emphasize so I think we'd want
to make sure that we could um spread it
spread the wealth I guess yeah what yeah
sure okay just just to be clear C in in
following representative bel's point
this bill does not require I read it do
not require students to write a stuff
all this bill does is promate policiy in
the school to opportunity to do that is
that correct that's exactly right and
some yes that's exactly right thank you
Mr chair representative Hall thank you
have a question thank you Mr speaker
thank you representative for taking my
question I'm just curious do we know how
many what percentage of seniors are 18
by the time they graduate you know I'm
thinking if you do this in the fall
there are not many yeah not many 18 year
olds yeah at that that's a that's a good
question I know my senior is it won't be
18 till June um and so but you can
register you can register to vote uh
when when you're going to turn 18 on the
next
election um my suspicion is that's
something that at the school level
they'll have a good hand of the timing
of it and if someone runs one in the
fall they might say well we had six you
know but we've got eight 80 that could
be in June so may I don't know I don't
know the exact number to be blunt about
that um but I take your point absolutely
thank you thank you representa cascaden
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question more of a clarification in
the language and the bill this I presume
is intended also for Charter
Schools yes the Civics yes exactly so I
would just recommend um on line three
that that be
clarified because a charter is not
necessarily A District
and not necessarily private now I don't
have the
yep it's it's the language yes thank you
thank you and thank you
yeah yep that's a good point any further
questions so we have five other people
wanting to speak here yes representa
Noble thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um on line eight
of the bill it says providing access to
and assistance with filing registration
applications can you give me an example
of what that would look like in the
classroom uh I think it if I think it
could be on the this this bill provides
to I think represent W wood Cox point a
provides a floor not a ceiling so I
think assistance could be you know
um uh this is the form you put in your
name your address whatever the
information is here's the here's the the
your town clerk is open on Tuesdays 2 to
6 where some them have you know
different hours um you would want to
that's when you'll have to file it that
could be the sort of the bottom of it
but I would leave that up to the
Educators in the building to sort of
figure out what the
best they know I
don't
yes and when they get to the section
where you need to fill in what your
party is how how are we going to direct
the students in that way I think there
are pretty good guidelines about um
teachers there there isn't there isn't
first of all there there isn't that
would that would go into the territory
that would be prohibited um and I think
um you know that's part of I think
teachers are pretty right now pretty um
cautious about uh their political views
um and and if that's the
question I don't I don't think that I
don't see that playing a
role okay thank you very much much uh
for representing Paige and thank you Mr
chair appreciate your coming thank you
um I'm going to limit it uh to about two
minutes for the people coming forward to
speak and I'd like to invite Janet Ward
from the League of Women Voters New
Hampshire Miss
chance good morning thank you for having
me speak before
you you have before you a bill that is
eminently sensible and appropriate given
that we are citizens of a representative
democracy House Bill
1014 concretely states that each school
district and private high school shall
adopt policies to promote student voter
registration the bill suggests ways that
such promotion of student voter
registration might be accomplished
requiring only that students be informed
of state requirements for voter
registration and that each School shall
provide
access to and assistance with
registration
applications the sponsors of this bill
wisely recognize that though there may
be B many school districts which
adequately promote student voter
registration there may be districts
which do
not rather than leave such a critical
civic responsibility to Chance House
Bill 1014 provides clear direction to
all school districts and private high
schools
this bill recognizes as Thomas Jefferson
did that democracies must educate young
citizens to understand what a democracy
is and what role they must actively play
in it if our democracy is to survive
indeed last year the legislature passed
Senate Bill 216 which calls for an
increase in time spent on Civics
education House Bill 1014 provides an
ideal opport opportunity to transform
lessons in history and government into
active citizen engagement simply put
1014 concretizes the words of Doris
hadock or granny d as she was widely
known she said democracy is not
something we have but something we do
young citizens must be educated to
appreciate this Truth House Bill
1014 is a way of protecting the Bedrock
of our democracy our right to vote I
urge you to support this Bill thank you
right on the
money any questions for Mrs Ward yes
represent
[Music]
Tanner your phone went off uh thank you
and thank you for coming and testifying
today I was wondering if you could give
us just a short uh description of the
League of Women Voters and what they do
the League of Women Voters was founded
to encourage enourage everyone women in
particular at its founding but now
encouraging it encourages everyone to
exercise their right to vote and they
are particularly interested of course in
young citizens and so that is why among
the other things they do the league
supports um public schools and the
inculcation in the young citizens of our
nation to appreciate what a democracy is
and it requires of
them thank
you uh yes go ahead you're nonpartisan
group is absolutely nonpartisan thank
you further questions um thank you Janet
thank you like to invite representative
Tim
Horgan oh thank you much Mr chair I'm
resident Timothy Horgan from straford
County District 10 with which is the
town of Durham um the uh which is uh the
home of the University of New Hampshire
um there's the main reason why this bill
is good is well it underlines the
importance of voting regards the way you
call yourselves a democracy or or a
constitutional republic um regardless of
which word you use um it's the citizen
you know the government like is you know
the citizens the people so you know and
I there was a question about like the
government compelling speech and I
understood the concern but the
government is not really
Force that's separate from the people
but um so I think this encourages young
people to vote it uh so you 18 you know
like when you're 18 years old that's
when a lot of your lifetime habits are
formed so if you register to vote you'll
get in the habit of voting and uh you'll
continue voting uh to your old as me or
even older as some members of the uh
committee uh may be although I find that
hard to believe so um I think this is a
very uh very simple Bill the schools um
should already be doing it um and the
comment about the chartered public
schools that uh that's a common problem
these education bill so that's probably
a simple Amendment with the private high
schools there may be some religious
groups who operate private high schools
who don't believe in voting but um I
don't know how many of them there are
here in New Hampshire so
probably probably we should uh probably
should leave that alone for now and if
it's if it's an issue it'll be uh the
first comes the where we can pass the
bill and somebody can challenge it and
probably U they would have the right not
to register their uh register their
students on on religious grounds so I
think this is a I think this is a good
bill and you should put it the charter
schools and pass it and um so I look
forward to voting for it on the floor
hopefully uh hopefully at the next
hopefully at the next session day so um
thank you very much thank you are there
any questions for the representative no
not seeing it thank you very much I'd
like to invite Olivia Z
open
democracy
yes good morning chairman lad and
members of the committee um my name is
Olivia zinc I'm a voter in Franklin New
Hampshire and the executive director of
open democracy we're a nonpartisan
nonprofit that represents about 36,000
voters um we um I'm submitting testimony
in favor of this bill I think it's very
important um that school districts
um give students um education about uh
registering to vote you'll see that I um
I'm passing around this report that was
done um by the Civic Center that show
15.6% of 18y olds in New Hampshire are
registered to vote when you look at the
school districts on the left-hand column
that have higher percentages it's
because Bedford um supervisor of the
checklist goes to the high school and
registers uh folks to vote the Keen
clerk goes to the high school and
registers um so the communities that are
higher than that conquer did a drive uh
I know that the uh uh hopkington
supervisor of the checklist will go to
the high school if requested and
register students to vote to to other
questions that have come up um Town
clerks and supervisors of the checklist
go to nursing homes go to other places
to register to vote but right now
there's about a dozen high schools
across the state that are registering
that that do do this kind of work and I
think it's important that all students
across the state have the opportunity to
know how to fill out their applications
to register to vote um and I know there
was a question raised earlier um in that
box you can put Republican Democrat or
Undeclared those are the three choices
of what parties you can put in the box
and many times supervisors of the
checklist or uh Town clerks do tell
people those are the three things that
you can put in those in the Box about
which parties to register um I know uh
when KET had a voter registration Drive
um former state senator Nancy Styles is
the uh supervisor the checklist and and
the majority of the students registered
as Undeclared so um that was a
conversation and students registered
Undeclared or they can pick a party if
they choose to so I think that that's a
simple instruction um I also have
testimony from representative former
Representative Bob Perry who was unable
to be here but I passed that around so
if you have questions you can read his
testimony thank you thank you very much
are there any questions
yes represent p no thank you Mr chair
and thank you for being here you
mentioned several schools that already
do this so I'm kind of concerned why we
need this legislation if there's nothing
in current state law that would prevent
a supervisor of the checklist from going
into the school and registering students
to vote I will say that this happens in
New Hampshire based on a student's
interest so in lonia three years ago
Ella um um a student wanted to run a
voter registration Drive the lonia high
school had one three years ago but
haven't had one since um in Portsmouth
the junior class sponsors the drive for
the senior class it was really done by a
parent uh of a senior who wanted this to
happen so it's very it's done Community
by community in a very localized way
based on it really takes students who
want to educate other students about how
to register to vote teachers willing to
partner School school districts and
supervisors of the checklist or town
clerks and there is no uniform require
you know it's not happening state by
state so it is UN in my opinion all New
Hampshire students should have the
ability to learn how to register to vote
and it shouldn't just be based on the
energy in one school or another that
there should be a this this legislation
is needed to promote uniform
policies do we need an RSA to promotee
that policy or could that be done
through an organization such as yours
going into the schools to work with the
the classroom teachers the the Civics
teachers the social studies teachers in
order to create that sort of momentum
does it have to come through state law I
will say our organization has worked on
this for three years and we have only
had a dozen school districts so there
could be organizations like open
democracy and the new and Civic Center
and other organizations that promote
this but I think um that is just you
know that's just we're if we had
something that required all school
districts to adopt a policy I think that
that would actually help promote this um
instead of just School District by a
school district so that the Bedford
school district has it the and some
other school districts have it but the
kids in Peterboro and conal District
don't aren't able to register to vote uh
because they don't have um a supervisor
the checklist coming to their school or
or doing other other things and I think
you know the charter school in Dairy
came to the town they did a field trip
to the town clerk two years ago and and
then the town clerk said oh maybe we
should go to the charter school next
year instead of having 40 people show up
40 students show up in our lobby and I
think sort of figuring out what that
means I live in the city of Franklin the
high school is walking distance to the
town clerk's office so they do a walking
field trip um to the town clerk's office
so I think it can happen differently um
in different school districts but I
think it there should be some incentive
for all school districts to be
participating um so that all high school
kids have this opportunity to learn how
to register to vote thank you uh
representa Woodcock thank you hi good
afternoon good morning anyhow um looking
at your statistics on your your blue
sheet uh you don't have to look at them
uh do you have any can you give us a
guesstimation or something close to
guesstimation of what it is National Al
the younger the percentage registration
for 18y olds I didn't see it in St um
26% Nationwide of 18 year olds are
registered to vote according to the
Civic Center data um it's a different
report but I do have a okay great thank
you thank you m so we are we are lower
in New Hampshire than other stes good
thank you are there further questions
repent Luna thank you very much Mr chair
and thanks thanks very much Olivia for
for taking my question um I was wonder
if you could talk with us a little bit
about um obstacles that students might
face in order to successfully um you
know register to
vote um I think well first of all
students have to produce their um
original birth certificate their uh
something that proves citizenship so
that could be their original birth
certificate a driver's license they have
to prove identity age citizenship and
domicile and many students may not have
utility bills in their own name they
might have a cell phone in their own
name with their address so that could be
used um they might have a car
registration um we are seeing the number
of 18yar olds um that have driver's
license reduced Nationwide um so uh 20
years ago the majority of 18-year-olds
had driver's license and you're seeing
that number closer to 60% according to
um a a the automat I forget which it's
the AAA the uh autom IC I forget the I
can find that
statistic thank you that Association um
but I do think that um if they don't
have those documents they can sign an
affidavit um but many students will not
know that um and also many students
don't realize that they can register to
vote if they're 17 and they'll turn 18
before the next election and so if I I
recommend students do drives in in June
because you have the majority of senior
that have um drives that are 18 in June
um but then by June they most of them
will be 18 by the next election so I
think that um uh we call it cap gown and
ballot project so uh when students are
picking up their cap and gown it's a
great time to invite those those high
school students to to also invite the
town clerk or um have uh supervisor
checklist there to to fill out those
forms very quick fall thank you um and I
I was actually really getting at trying
to get at uh and thanks for that answer
I think that that brings a lot with it
but really looking at underserved
populations that may have challenges
with transportation and things like that
and and how this may help to overcome
some of those um uh structural um uh
obstacles that um that certain students
might have to participating in
democracy yeah thank you thank you for
that question and I do think
um having this information available at
school it gives a foundation you know
only 60% of New Hampshire kids go on to
college so if they're getting
information about how to register to
vote at College you're missing 40% of
that population but I also think there
is sort of so social social and economic
uh situations where um some families
might have those documents ready for
their 18 year-olds and some families may
have had a house fire or some other way
where those documents aren't readily
available and I think
um equalizing that is an important thing
um having transportation to go to the
town clerk's office in many um
communities they're only open especially
in the North Country they're only open
you know a few hours a week and um sort
of not standardized hours so I think um
you know it was interesting when we
looked at the kennet school district in
Conway the hours of the supervisors of
the checklist of those nine Regional
School District and there isn't much
availability for students to get there
during the hours of the town clerk I
mean they can go on Election Day so that
does provide us an additional
opportunity for those students that want
to do same day registration thank
you further questions not see thank you
very much I'd like to invite Katherine
langle good
morning
good morning chairman lad and
distinguished members of the House
Education committee uh my name is
Katherine LEL and I'm a 20- year old
voter in conquered New Hampshire I'm
submitting testimony in support of House
Bill 1014 this describes well youall
know what it
describes uh in our current political
climate discussions regarding young
people's inclination to participate in
governmental processes or the lack
thereof are exceptionally be are finally
being heard um um this topic has gone
Nationwide influencing campaign
decisions of candidates for president of
the United States and young voters have
historically been underrepresented in
elections often due to a lack of
knowledge surrounding the process of
registering to vote it has been seen
that young voters when they use their
voice can make significant changes in
the outcome of an election I actually
just read a report of research that
marked New Hampshire as one of the
states to watch in the presidential
primary because of young
voters so in my testimony I discussed
the same RSA that um the representative
who sponsored the bill I'm blanking on
their name um brought up where Section
504 plans and individualized education
plans um are required to include
discussion on quote voter registration
as an appropriate Community Living
citizenship training goal or competency
to be included in their plan and if
appropriate when and how voter
registration should be accomplished this
discussion is vital for students who may
be facing a disability or barrier to
accessing resources as was mentioned um
and the concepts described in this
competency are completely transferable
to general education
classrooms um and this would allow for
all students to gain understanding of
real world Concepts that are applicable
after graduation I graduated conquered
High School in 2022 and then went to
participate in the midterm elections
that following November
but that's only because I registered to
vote and I had the opportunity to do my
own research on how to in fact I brought
more documentation than I needed into
the town clerk's office I had no idea
what I was doing um as a young voter
myself this bill and the impact it could
have on Civics education and youth
participation in government really
stands out to me
um yeah I mean students are required to
buy law to spend a significant amount of
time I said 7 hours 5 days a week if
that's not correct please correct me um
in school and aiding them in the process
of becoming an active member of their
Community seems like a very valuable way
to spend that time I now attend St anom
College which is one of the most
prolific centers of community engagement
in the state and not even everyone there
is registered to vote so thank you very
much Katherine are there any questions
for Katherine represent
dry thank you Mr chairman thank you for
coming to
testify there are other elections
besides national elections and state
elections um have you figured into it
you know participating in town
governments as well as um as national
elections absolutely and I feel like
that's an important conversation to have
as well in Civics education classrooms
the biggest thing that I got from this
bill was that Civics education and
Community engagement in theory is
significantly different from Civics
education and C like Civic engagement in
practice taking the information that you
learn in the classroom about Municipal
elections State elections and
presidential elections and actually
going out and participating them in them
there's a clear Gap or lag as was
mentioned I toward the state house and
the um yeah I sorted the state house and
all the chambers when I was in like
fourth or fifth grade I remember that
but then when I got to high school not a
single person was talking about that
anymore because it was in elementary
school so that lag and that disconnect
between theory and practice is is clear
and I feel like this bill would uh
standardize that in policy thank you
very much representative P
now thank you Mr chair and thank you for
being here you are clearly well ahead of
the curve for somebody your age when it
comes to Civic engagement how did you
become aware of this
bill so I actually became aware of this
bill because I'm looking into uh I want
to create my career surrounding uh civic
education and working in a school
ideally combining psychology education
and public policy together which is what
my degree will be in um so understanding
this bill and paying attention to what's
going on is very important to me um I
also had the opportunity of teaching
high schoolers uh at as a
you know like a teacher essentially in
uh at my college in an after school
program for them and I taught College
admissions so I spoke with a lot of high
school seniors about registering to vote
and uh this conversation I feel like
could only be
Amplified thank you very much yeah pen
now follow up I'm sorry you didn't quite
answer my question are you following
legislation that is pertains to Civics
is that how you found it I'm just
curious okay yes
thank
you any further questions thank you very
much Katherine Catherine I'm sure a lot
of elementary kids would love to have
you for their
teacher and I'd love to come talk to
them thank you so much and our last
speaker is uh representative
Damon thank you Mr chair good morning
colleagues I'm a co-sponsor of this bill
and vigor who support it one of the
reasons I ran for State Rep was to do
whatever I could to help young people be
more engaged in our government processes
and appreciate the impact of government
on them I am mentoring a sunap high
school senior inter senior project Jenna
Karen who very unfortunately was not
able to be here today um her project is
on voter engagement in local elections
so the question a moment ago about local
mattering as well as state and federal
is on some people's
radar um there are five high schools in
the nin toown District that I represent
and because two of those high schools
are Cooperative schools they educate
students from 16 towns I pulled them
none of those high schools provide voter
registration
information by default to students it is
as was referenced uh I think by Olivia
zinc contingent on a motivated person
who decides to do that in a given year
it's not a
routine I think it is an essential piece
of our democracy that we help students
readily understand how they can register
to vote and make it convenient for them
to do
so I'd like to address the question from
representative Noble about the party um
indication on the on the voter
registration I will bring forward an
amendment to this bill in committee to
specify
in uh line eight where it says providing
access to an assistance with filing
registration applications to
specifically say without any influence
on party affiliation so that there's no
uncertainty about that being
inappropriate to
do I thank you all for your
consideration and I really hope that we
can find our bipartisan voices because
all voters matter and all students
should be able to be voters thank
you pretty good timing
there yeah obviously you don't want any
questions we can do it during EXA
session as well are there any questions
for the representative representative
beler thank you Mr chair and thank you
for that testimony um one thing I wanted
to look at is the the latter part of
this bill which um it does say that it
can't be utilized as a class requirement
um
however it seems to me that there's a
lot of other potential carrots and
sticks that are not directly addressed
in this bill even things like sports
participation so how can we be sure that
schools won't actually look to any of
those other items that are not
specifically listed in this bill as a
way to compel or coor students toward
registration thank you for the
question
I don't have
a process for how you would itemize
every imaginable thing
that in some people's minds could happen
but I don't perceive that as a
risk thank
you thank you very
much when you mention AA a lot of us are
thinking a a
RP not all of them
okay so that this concludes the hearing
for
10:14 and we're ready to go into now the
hearing for
1048 this is a bill relative to
Commission on Holocaust and genocide
education oh
Bob the 50
right the 50
[Laughter]
right
okay
so thank
you as the prime sponsor of this bill we
welcome you represent
wolf I should turn that
on um I'm here on a relatively simple
request did you give us card House Bill
1048 is for the date of the final report
of the commission on Hol Holocaust and
genocide education to be extended
until November 1st
2027 the report is due in November of
this
year the bill simply changes the date at
the end of section 193
d2f to November 1
2027 the reason for this extension was
that even though the bill was effective
on July 23rd 2020 it was not operational
until nearly 2 years later June 9th of
2022 the commission was not organized
and did not complete drafting operating
criteria to send to the Board of
Education until January 22nd of
21 the doe did not approve the rules
until April 14th of
2022 jel car approved the rules a month
later in May of 22 and the rules became
effective in June of
2022 the commission believes that at
least four years of academic studies is
needed for the imple implementation of
the bill to make sure that the bill is
achieving the intended results as was
provided for in the original
legislation this bill provides for four
academic years before the final report
is due
this legislation will restore the
original intent of the
bill I'm going to ask following me is
superintendent Brian balky who is
Chairman of a committee who can answer a
lot of questions on the various
committees that have been organized and
what has been done to date on
this
um also I ask have you gotten the uh
written report comments from senator
Cindy Rosenwald no I think they were
emailed
in I will check
and make sure they do get
emailed um and I'm here to answer any
questions that you want and I ask
superintendent balky to come and join
me are there any qu questions of
Representative
wolf representative belshire thank you
Mr chair I'd just like to ask as far as
your work to date goes and and what
you're looking at as far as can you can
you provide a list of of what um
historical genocide events you're
currently looking at recommending be
covered I certainly can but I think
Brian balky would do a much more
thorough job so that's fair enough he
can follow
up want to come up well hold on second
hold on I I I'll get the order of who
comes forward first okay um my apology
are there any any uh questions uh
represent wolf tradition is in the
in the house here that we have
Representatives here at the beginning
and waiting we try to get them out of
here so I'd like to call forward
representa
Lynn thank you Mr you're
welcome uh representative wolf we also
need a pink card from
you thank thank you Mr chair I I'll be
very brief representative wolf really
said virtually everything that I would
that I would say and uh much better than
I would say it I'm sure I would just say
that I strongly support the extension it
seems to me that the the pandemic you
know really did have a uh a delaying
effect uh on this on this legislation
it's very important I think the getting
uh getting the uh the commission to be
able to review the the results of the uh
of the St of the evaluation done by the
education department when they've when
they've completed that and having some
time to see how this is uh is working is
is very important and so I urge you uh
uh to pass this leg to vote favorably to
pass this legislation and I'm happy to
take any questions thank you any
questions of represent Lyn I do have one
for you given the nature what's going on
today's
society with the uh issues we've seen on
various college campuses and throughout
the country dealing with semantic um
issues you know with the the Holocaust
and etc etc um is that rationale good
rationale for us to really pursue this
for another few years um sure no I mean
I think that I I think I I think it it
on its on the merits of it even if we
didn't have what was going on now it
would be it would be a good that would
in itself uh would be a good reason to
to extend it but particularly given what
um what we've seen going on around the
country um and what effect you know
we've seen this
mostly um this kind of behavior on
college campuses but I I can't help but
believe that it's got that that that is
going to have some influence on what's
happening at the lower in the lower uh
grades in the educational system and so
it would be it would seem to me that it
would be important for um for the
evaluation to to have some additional
time to see you know what what
effect uh the recent events have had
which are you know I mean if if if
somebody had said to
me you know six months ago that we would
see the kind of behavior anti-semitic
Behavior public anti-semitic Behavior I
mean anti-Semitism has always existed uh
but you know at least at least in the
not too distant past it was it uh
uh it it was not the kind of open thing
that we're seeing now but if somebody
had said to me and I suspect you all of
you would have the same view somebody
had said to to any of any of us six
months ago that we would see the kind of
public anti-semitic behavior that we've
seen on you know on the on our nation's
supposedly finest uh colleges I I think
would say you're you know you're you're
crazy that's that's just ridiculous but
look what we've seen yeah it's sad uh
further questions representative
cordelli thank you thank you
representative for being here um I just
wanted to follow up on comment you made
in also that representative wolf made um
I see in the charge to the commission
that it should monitor
implementation but there was indication
that um there was a requirement to
um uh make sure that the desired results
are being provided I'm not sure what
those desired results are and who is
going to be uh determining um whether
the results are uh being uh provided
that are
desired I I I guess I'm I'm going to
have to say that I I have not at all I'm
not on the commission and I have not at
all been involved in the details of that
I believe uh that uh representative wolf
made reference to another witness uh who
have that information I would have to
defer to him yeah y thank you further
questions thank you very much judge
thank thank
you like to call Brian
balky thank you chairman lad good
morning good morning uh my name is Brian
baly I'm the superintendent of schools
in in New Boston representing sau9 and I
also have the privilege of serving on
the commission um as a representative of
the New Hampshire school administrators
Association uh as representative wolf
shared our request is simply to extend
the date um at this point we feel like
there's been a delay in uh this work
moving forward and when we've when the
commission first started we essentially
broke our work into three categories the
first was um policy the second was best
practices and the third was
implementation the policy work that we
did is we helped draft Draft rules that
went to the State Board of Education and
then ultimately on to Jael car the work
that work is essentially done the rules
have been passed it's implemented uh
that part of the commission's work is
completed the best practices work I do
see is ongoing I think that um this is
something that we will continue to need
to provide resources for teachers and
schools but the third part I think is
really the the focus of the commission
extension
the implementation piece there simply
hasn't been enough time to know whether
the rules are being followed whether
school districts need additional
supports and resources and that's
essentially what we're here asking uh
this morning so uh the Department of
Education is doing um a survey right now
that all School principles have to
complete it's called the input-based
accountability system or ibass as the
department calls it in that survey all
schools have to report out on whether
whether they're meeting the requirements
of Hol and genocide um Holocaust and
genocide education as it's required at
the middle school and high school levels
we haven't collected that data yet those
reports aren't due until next week I
think it makes good sense to wait and
see let's see what whether schools have
implemented this as they're supposed to
and I think more importantly and really
this is the focus that I want to uh
focus on how do we help
teachers teaching about the Holocaust or
other genocides is pretty tricky it's
it's complicated and we want to make
sure that we're supporting the field and
giving resources and supports to
teachers um representative belter asked
specifically about some of the content I
would uh refer you to um Keen state
college has um has a has a Coen center
that is focused the Coen Center is
focused on Holocaust and genocide
education and they've developed a
website that has a number of resources
and supports that ranges from um
recommended books to lesson plans that
teachers can follow different resources
that teachers can use um as they do this
work um I'll I'll stop there and be
brief and ask if there are any questions
but that's essentially um the nature of
this
bill represent dry thank you Mr chairman
thank you for coming for to our
committee um in the statute it said that
an annual report was to be start
submitted starting November 1st of 21
and every year thereafter did you do
anything in 21 22 or 2 yeah the the
reports have been I think it's every
other year the last report that was
submitted was done so by Senator Khan
when he was the the chair of the
commission I think that was the last one
that we sub that we submitted okay
follow yeah it does say every year
thereafter do you know what year that
was I believe that was either last year
or it might have been the year before
okay thank
you further questions yes represent Cass
Cen thank you Mr chair thank you
superintendent
uh my question is about the curriculum
and the teaching materials and you
mentioned that you're collecting data on
how many schools are
implementing um my question is is there
going to be a recommended curriculum for
schools and or are they allowed to just
pull their resources from wherever they
find them to be able to yeah the the
commission the commission has not
endorsed any particular curriculum or
curricula plural um there have been a
number of resources through the Cohen
Center but I think at this point we want
to continue to provide resources to
teachers but certainly not sanctioning
any particular um
curriculum and a follow up to that I I
I've uh worked with several students
from the Coen Center over at Keane is
there a person there that's a contact
for Tom white pardon me Mr Tom white Tom
um I I'm not entirely sure what his
exact title is I think it might be the
education coordinator but but Tom white
also serves on the commission and he is
is an incredible resource he does
professional development around the
state for teachers currently thank you
are there further
questions thank you very much thank you
for your time oh we yeah rapan belter
thank you Mr here I'll make this one
quick I I haven't had a lot of time to
look through it I just looking through
the Coen uh website what I see is the
two specific incidents they're bringing
up for genocide um are of course the
Holocaust and also uh the current
situation in
Ukraine um of course the Holocaust being
a product of fascism and ideas generally
being what give rise to these genocide
movements um nobody nobody would doubt
that the Holocaust Education is
necessary and good but I haven't
historically seen a lot of um emphasis
on another ideology specifically
communism and the atrocities that it was
responsible for is there any uh intent
to recommend certain genocidal events
such as ma or um paulot or any of the
others yeah so certainly school
districts would be permissible to focus
on any particular genocide that they'
they'd like to right so in addition
there are things happening right now
around the world in Sudan in darur look
at what's happening in Myanmar there
there are a number of other really good
current examples and they um certainly
would kind of fall within different
constructs of government so the the
commission is not saying this genocide
is more important than another genocide
in any way historically it's just saying
that we need to teach people about the
importance of knowing what these uh
genocides have been historically and
hopefully prevent them moving forward
particularly given that they're still
happening in this day and
age yes representative petel thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for being here
um if my memory serves correctly the
last statistic that I've heard was 65
million 65 million pre-born children
have been killed by abortion in our
country since
1973 has there been any any conversation
during the commission meetings regarding
instruction in this ongoing genocide in
our own country that predominantly
targets the African-American
Community um I don't
recall further
questions thank you very much thank
you i' like to
uh welcome Reverend ham
Harmon New Hampshire Council of churches
y thank you
good morning honorable Representatives
uh my name is Reverend Zachary Haron I
live at nine Spring Street in gtown New
Hampshire I'm an Episcopal priest
serving uh at St Christopher in Hamstead
New Hampshire and I'm also on the uh
Holocaust and genocide education
commission as the representative for the
New Hampshire Council of churches I'm
here to speak in support of HB 1048
extending the work of the Holocaust and
genocide education
commission I feel the importance of this
work cannot be
overstressed well it might seem like the
horrors of the Holocaust could never be
forgotten I've heard from Educators and
community members about concerning
incidents of anti-Semitism and even
Holocaust denial at times if the
Holocaust is forgotten minimized or
misremembered I believe this opens the
door for further rises in anti-Semitism
and dehumanization of people by their
National ethnicity or
religion if we do not study the
Holocaust or genocide then we as a
society can lose track of the dangers of
hate in my experience as a priest I also
know that there are other important
genocides to consider and which should
not be forgotten my Parish Ministry uh
connects me at times with the Armenian
American Community here in New Hampshire
and many Armenians uh came to New
England in desperation to escape the
horrors of the Armenian Genocide
in the education rules there is also now
a helpful list of genocides and mass
atrocities from which Educators can
draw from learning about the Holocaust
and genocide students are equipped to be
thoughtful citizens it is hoped that
this knowledge about the dangers of hate
and the history of genocide will help
prevent genocide in the
future and perhaps the most relevant
question here in regards to HB 1048
though uh would be why continue this
work all the way to 20 27 for the
commission and the simple answer is that
due to delays caused by covid Holocaust
and genocide education has only just
begun to be implemented in the state a
little over a year ago while the
commission was put together and and has
put together some good and helpful
guidelines and while the Coen Center for
Holocaust and genocide studies has been
very helpful in providing resources for
educators more time is needed to track
implementation and to help meet the
needs of school administrators and
educator S as they begin teaching this
subject I would also note that time is
of the essence as the number of
Holocaust Survivors becomes fewer and
fewer as the years pass it is important
that we uh is important that we uh begin
implementing this effectively sooner
rather than later for all these reasons
I hope you will support passing HB 1048
thank you for your time thank you very
much are there any questions for the
Reverend yes represent dry thank you Mr
chairman thank you for coming
um are you planning if we extend this
till 2027 is there a plan to do any
annual reports in the
interim I you know we certainly plan to
continue in reporting you know regularly
and I would think annually would make
sense and followup yeah because I know
rep representative belch would want to
ask that but he's not here the list you
talked about of events to draw from what
where is that that's education rules
30649 okay thank you so much yeah
further questions representative
petel I'm just confused I'm actually
pretty
old and I certainly remember learning
about the Holocaust when I was a child
probably read The Diary of an Frank
multiple times is there a period in our
the history of education in the state of
New Hampshire where we haven't been
teaching any of these
topics so you know what we're looking
for is to have something organized that
ensures that students are are taught
effectively because you know with um uh
social media and things that are out
there for students to draw from uh it's
important to have a stable voice that
can point to to the history and not have
people uh you know uh confused you know
for instance um I I grew up in Alaska
and I have uh you know friends that are
teachers in Alaska and you know I I hear
students from from some of my friends
that are teachers talking about kids
that are telling them that the Holocaust
never happened and so um you know it is
and if it can happen all the way out in
rural Alaska it can certainly happen
here in you know in New Hampshire as
well uh so you know I think um it's
important there's probably been some
consistency of teaching I would imagine
it's been brought up around World War II
or other uh School discussions but what
we're looking for is to have consistency
given given their eyeses that we've seen
an anti-Semitism incidents and trying to
provide good education for students
just a little followup on that um I
lived in Alaska as an educator for 25
years in Homer it's part of the
curriculum so it's you know represent
cordelli um thank you I just wanted to
follow up on the anti semitic um
incidents that been happy that
representative Lynn and you both
mentioned um I was just reading this
weekend um it's not just any
semitism um Christians are also um
Nigeria there were a 100
Christians uh executed on Christmas Day
and over
45,000 over the past decade as I
recall a
question would you
believe I I would like not to believe
but but you know we hear stories that
you are there further questions thank
you very much I have no uh other cards
for this bill so with that we'll close
hearing thank
you the we'll take a break and we'll
pick the next one up and in about 5
minutes at
11:15
welcome back we have uh one more Bill uh
to deal with before our uh lunch break
um I think everyone's back in the room
um this is House Bill 1163 relative to
review of public school minimum
standards by the Legislative over site
commission and um I call on chairman lad
to introduce the bill well thank you
very much uh represent cordelli and
members of the committee I'm here to
today to introduce 1163 this is a bill
that deals with the minimum standards uh
for public school approval and the
relationship of those standards with the
legislative oversight committee um in
the system we have for oversight which
is in 198 Colon c
18 the state has Authority currently and
establish to establish the minimum
public minimum standards for public
school approval and the academic
standards for delivery of an of
educational services so the state board
has that Authority and currently the
oversight commission uh uh committee has
approval for oversight and consideration
of the academic
standards so what this bill does it puts
the oversight in the position of being
now responsible for oversight of both
the minimum standards for public school
approval and the academic standards for
the delivery of an educ of educational
services and I passed out a paper to you
there and I'll start off right there in
the second
paragraph throughout the previous year
the State Board of Education has engaged
in a process to update and revise Ed
306 the minimum standards for public
school
approval this bill expands legislative
oversight committee responsibility to
allow review and make recommendations
related to those standards those School
approval
standards the oversight committee
currently has responsibility for View
and consideration only of the academic
standards now when we were looking at
the 306 rules that came to us the
proposed the draft copy in initially you
can recall that there are certain areas
within the sections within Ed
306 which dealt specifically with
subjects or the criteria for a
substitute education as identified in 13
e e colon
2A those are the areas which we have in
an adequate
education in
306 we also have rules for those
sections of
law we have it for sections of art
English health and wellness physical
education uh technical s Technologies
mathematics science social studies World
languages
Etc the ability of the State Board to
change anything in
306 is not
allowed we've been told that by folks
from the Department when they came here
to testify you remember Nate green came
forward and said we've changed made
recommendations to change 306 and all
these other areas but we have not
touched the
306 that was a result of we of the
language which is in statutory law right
now which once these have been set for
these subject areas they can't be
changed without statutory authority of
the general
court
and that's something that represent my
has spoken to often so what this does
then if we're going to have the minimum
standards for public school approval
approved by the state board and gone
through Jael car and that there has to
be oversight from this committee from
the legislative oversight committee uh
due to the fact that we are responsible
for anything that occurs with the
substant criteria for an adequate
education so what this bill does it just
it puts in that responsibility same as
we have for academic standards now when
you're looking at these academic
standards or the minimum standards you
often times have been you'll told go
look at the Frameworks and we'll deal
with that in the next bill later on here
today right after lunch uh these two
bills are related to each other and so
I'll conclude this part of the testimony
stating that it's important that there
be more oversight coming from the Ed the
general court regarding rules in 306 306
covers just about everything we do in
education from in the school's
perspective and it's important that we
make sure that nothing's changed in the
area of that substantive criteria
without oversight from this committee
thank
you uh thank you repres questions thank
you chair
uh thank you representa L uh just a
procedural information for me Rick what
what is the oversight committee's uh
ability to do impact anything I see
review and
recommend I just can
you that's the response it's review and
make
recommendations you can't go much
further than that because we
can't Implement a pocket veto we can't
have state this statutory language tell
them to do something then come back and
reconsider it through you know a a
committee or a commission okay so but we
can make recommendations that you're not
following what we have established or
you're making changes without if you
look at
193e it's specifically stated that
nothing can be done to these areas of
law right now these subject areas
without General Court approval that's
right there in that same section 19 93e
colon
3 I believe it's colon 3 I may be wrong
with that but Mr chair may just follow
up yes follow up thank you um so from
that then if if the committee find I'm
just TR I just don't understand if the
committee finds uh or make a
recommendation to who does that go to it
goes back to the State Board state board
yes yes it's just like with the academic
standards we currently have you can't
change academic standards without the
oversight committee looking at reviewing
it and making recommendation okay to the
state board and there's no requ there's
no they could fact go forward with it if
they wanted okay all right but it' be
Doc so documented that we were not in
concurrence all right thank you thank
you Mr chair sure uh further questions
um I have one um representative lad
maybe you want to touch on I think that
there's new um procedure in place for
policy committee review of rules also
generally yes you know the you know how
rules are made by put together by the uh
State Board of Education in our regard
right here by any Bureau uh uh uh agency
Etc does the same thing those rules go
to hearing and go through the process
just like we do hearings here they come
back to the state board and but they
have to also pass their rule proposals
those Draft rules to Jael car The Joint
legislative committee administrative
rules which then looks at that and their
responsibility and the committee that we
now have is to when they bring that
forward any changes must now go to the
Joint legislative committee and
administrative rules committee that we
have to ensure that the intent of the
law the that they're putting together
rules that parallel what we have in law
it's for example remember some of you
May when we would put together that we
were requiring four years of mathematics
instruction in high schools three years
are required credits but the fourth year
is one where it's embedded it's embedded
in a course which is approved by a local
school
board when they make the rules they
would then have to make sure that the
language which we have in statute is
also reflective in rules they did that
uh many times so when we write
legislation we don't write it
specifically uh and we leave a lot of
room for the the State Board to make
rules of how to implement that um
so that's the time that it has to come
back to us and say is that being
implemented in with paralleling the
intent and what we see as the the
rationale for that particular law that
we put in place that's important that we
now have that option we have these rules
306 will have to come back to the that
committee you're talking about that we
set up this year between the ranking
leader in the house and the speaker sat
down and said yes we're going to have
this committee Jael car was getting so
much coming to them that the
representatives on Jael car may have
come from Ways and Means or may have
come from uh egg or another committee
they didn't know what was going on in
education so things were slipping
through into rules which maybe shouldn't
have yes represent
D thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my
question could you inform us about the
current timeline for the review of the
minimum standards and the specifics of
where that process is at
please I don't work for the Department
nor the state board of education however
they we have been told that
they they did all the
hearings and there were there's rumor at
one point in time that they were going
to adopt those rules in November they
did not uh we were informed that by Mr
Green when he came here to the committee
I I do not know the specific date in
which they're going to be doing that
those rules will come forward uh but I'm
sure that if we have uh Miss Fenton here
behind me I
think yeah she's here and she'll get
elevated to Colonel if she can give us
the answer
that later
on any for yes representative luno so
thank you Mr chair and thanks for uh for
for bringing this one forward
representative lad would um would it be
fair to sort of call this um Bill a
housekeeping bill as as it already says
as you pointed out in 193
e2a that um that the uh the State Board
shall not amend any existing academic
standards and shall not approve any new
academic standards without the prior
review and recommendation of the
legislative oversight committee
established in 193 c8a which is the
section of law that this amends so it
basically is just clarifying that the
State Board can't approve any rules or
any any changes to the standards unless
the legislative oversight committee
reviews and approves those um reviews
and recommends those
standards and that the charge of the
legislative oversight committee includes
the approval and recommendation of such
standards you're 80% of the way there um
this isn't this isn't changing what I'm
asking not it's not changing the um the
the requirement that the oversight
committee review and
recommend proposed changes when you and
I and others put together the bill where
we rewrote the oversight committee right
we included academic standards which had
been in statute prior to that we never
touched upon the area of minimum
standards the standards which we go out
to approve
schools which goes everything from the
gamut of you know
um professional development and
maintenance Casto you know all that it
has everything to do with a school we're
talking about a specific component here
uh within the minimum uh uh standards
for public school approval which
contains possibly academic
standards and that's why it's important
that we have the oversight committee
looking at both of these issues the the
the academic standards which we'll speak
to at
12:45 ask somebody where those academic
standards are located right now and you
may have a problem finding them some are
in the Frameworks the old Frameworks
some are separate standards which have
been approved like the uh new gened
standards for science the specifically
in the
online um so we we got to get that part
clarified but this part right here I
think it's extremely and I think it is
more of a it's a technical cleanup that
we need to do uh we've had some problems
when we're looking at 306 initially
saying is this part of our
responsibility or not part of our
responsibility and we were also looking
at that adequacy statute which said yeah
it is part of our stat our
responsibility so what we're trying to
re uh replicate in through this process
here with the oversight committee I
believe is in parallel to what we are
required to do in statute right now
great great thank you yeah any further
questions see none thank you very much
you're
welcome uh Christine
Downing and I was wondering if maybe you
could cut down the length of time that
you requested a little bit
sure thank
[Music]
you
thank you committee members for allowing
me to speak to you today I'm Christine
Downing I reside at 42 Brickyard Road
Goan New Hampshire for the past 15
months I volunteered to make uh sure the
voice of Educators have been considered
in the current 306 review process I have
battled to make sure transparency and
State uh and stakeholders representing
all facets of public schools are part of
this process when my single voice wasn't
enough I sought the power of the press
to make this important work public no
one citizen should uh who happens to
have 30 years of educational experience
should have to go through these steps to
engage in something that is very
Foundation to what defines our Public
Schools I applaud representative lad and
others for this bill I'm encouraged by
the B bipartisan support for this bill I
see it as a first step in making any
review of the minimum standards for
public school approval as transparent
and open to stakeholders as possible
starting from day one throughout the
entire process as RSA 193 E-1 section 2
States and adequate education should be
provided through an integrated system of
shared responsibility between state and
local
government through much of the current
review process this work has been done
in a very closed door and non-inclusive
manner thus leading to much speculation
regarding proposed changes the review
process and decisions relative to what
changes are put for forth should not
rest in the hands of a single person the
review process should be accessible to
the public and inclusive of stakeholders
that represent our Public Schools while
I support this first step I would
encourage this committee to consider
amendments to this bill that would
include the establishment of a minimum
standards for public school commission
this type of commission would parallel
and I I want to note before I say this I
had no idea that the bill on genocide
and Holocaust Education was coming
before me but this type of commission
would parallel the same purpose and
structure that was inserted in RSA 193
e2f relative to Holocaust genocide um to
Holocaust and genocide education when I
conducted educator review sessions on
the March 9th 2023 draft of the 306
rules The Limited positive feedback I
received from Educators was related to
section
306-4955 articulate the expectations for
Holocaust and genocide education
Educators appreciated the clarity of
this section I surmise this was because
the commission was designed to establish
these rules throughout the involvement
of key stakeholders the lesson to take
away from this model if we want our
public schools to be their very best
then involves stakeholders who have the
biggest impact in making such rules a
reality for our students I have drafted
uh possible amendments relative to the
establishment of a commission I'd be
willing to work with representatives to
bring forth this idea as part of this
bill since my executive semary was
released in the Boston Globe in October
real conversation about the rules and
how to move Public Schools forward have
occurred I have facilitated a group of
stakeholders through five dayong
meetings during November and December
with the next one coming this Friday on
January 12th however it's should not
have been this arduous and process void
of accessibility and transparency for
stakeholders I support this bill and
potential amendment that makes it clear
that future efforts will be required to
be transparent and inclusive for all
stakeholders thank you for your time and
attention and I will entertain questions
thank you very much uh representative
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
being here and for your ongoing work to
address the critical minimum
standard I have two questions at least
the first one is the same one I asked
representative lad can you share with us
your understanding of the current rule
making process and timeline for the
minimum standards please yes repres
representative Damon I I can share that
um as of a December 22nd meeting that
was conducted at Nea New Hampshire um
involving myself Mark McLean who's the
executive director of New Hampshire
school administrative ERS uh Megan
Tuttle president of uh New Hampshire Nea
IR Richardson also a member of Nea New
Hampshire um Val zanak member of the 306
task force and
NCCA Fred bermonte Robert MC glin um and
who am I missing Nathan Harris um we met
with the commissioner and proposed a
timeline he had also come back to us and
said that we needed to be ready to go to
present a draft for the February board
meeting it's my understanding the
February 8th board meeting has been
adjusted to the February 15th board
meeting I believe it's at this board
meeting the rules will be unted um and
is likely from that point they will
enter into their rul making phase and at
that point I believe a public hearing
will need to be held within 45 days but
I'm sure miss Fenton uh can confirm for
us that um our group has been giving uh
has been given a 4mon period of time uh
to conduct educator review sessions of
the content areas specifically in the
rules that's sections 31 through 48 of
the rules those are all the areas that
representative lad alluded to Define um
what makes an adequate education so we
are working very quickly to build
educator review sessions throughout the
state we are trying to do this in the
five different regions of the state um
and have representative Educators from
elementary middle and high school levels
to review the content areas there's been
much discussion in our work about what
needs to ret be retained in those areas
um because there's discussion around are
the academic content standards that
exist this the state level enough to
Define what should occur in those for to
Define an adequate education um and we
don't have complete consensus among our
group um and so we felt as none of us
are practitioners in these particular
content areas that we need the voices of
our Educators to get good feedback um
our goal is to put forth recommendations
by April 30th to the commissioner which
then can be brought to the state board
that is my working knowledge of the
plans moving forward from now through
April thank
you so quite frankly is that four Monon
timeline less than that from now till
April 30th adequate for the work that
you have outlined to hear from the
stakeholders at elementary middle high
school grade levels in all these content
areas and fully report back um
professionally speaking it's a tight
timeline um I'm not sure it's going to
produce the quality feedback we might um
have if we could have a full 180 days I
understand that if the Board needs to go
into Ru making in February then at the
you know the maximum amount that it can
allow is the 180 days um minimum is 20
days from my working knowledge of the
process um 180 days from approximately
February 15th would put us at August
15th it'd be nice to have an assurance
that we are really not looking at um
solidly approving these rules until that
August deadline because what's what's
going to be rushed is the analysis
that's going to need to be done on the
feedback of these sessions we're
planning these sessions to occur about
middle of February through the end of
March keep mind we lose basically two
weeks in February because we have a
split state in terms of when everybody
takes their February Vacations so we're
we're working very quickly my goal is to
have the announcement and registrations
for these sessions out by the end of
this week registrations for those will
close on February 2nd um and sessions
will start on February 12th so we're
moving pretty quickly in trying to get
the voice of the Educators in um
producing um standards Within These
content areas May um that that need to
do the job they should do which is to
ensure we have a high quality adequate
education in the state of New Hampshire
thank you any further questions
representative luno so thank you very
much Mr chair thank you very much M
Downing for joining us this morning so
um am I hearing you am I hearing this
right then that that it sounds like the
commissioner and the State Board of
Education are trying to move through the
um the proposed
minimum standard uh changes to the
minimum standards um despite the fact
that we have House Bill
1163 in consideration right now and to
get those minimum standards approved by
the state board
before um uh
1163 could be considered and signed into
law I can't speculate on the state board
or the commissioner or their intentions
I do know there is concern about the
rules
expiring um and I believe there are
other recourses in place that can that
can adjust that concern versus trying to
move very quickly um in getting these
through um the sense that our team has
been given is that we really need to get
things moving um and because I again
maybe we rely on Miss Fenton to let us
know exactly when the rules are expiring
and those expiration dates but I I think
all along there's been a sense that
March 2024 is a target date for these
rules um and given that they did go to
the board and they got tabled um and
they've been you know discussed um in
terms of being tabled in the last few
months I couldn't really represented
luno begin to speculate you know what
the intentions of the commissioner or
the State Board are I I'm simply
involved in this process to make sure we
have the best standards possible for our
public schools and ultimately our public
school students um and I think the way
to do that and I think the Holocaust and
genocide is a perfect model is if we
want the best rules possible let's bring
the stakeholders to the table and that's
why I've offered today the consideration
of an amendment to form a commission so
that what has occurred in this last
review process doesn't have the
opportunity to occur in the future which
basically would eliminate these going
out to some soul soul Source contract
and that this actually becomes the
direct responsibility of the Department
of Education I did work for the
Department of Education through multiple
roles um in the mid 2000s through about
2012 um and and it was part of my
function as mathematics consultant at
the department at that time to run
educator reviews of our rules whenever
we needed to adjust or change them um
and the fact that this process was
devoid of that for so long was very
concerning to me um so I can't speculate
thank you very
much I've seen no further question
questions thank you very much and uh
representative
lad a as the prime sponsor of this bill
the only sponsor of the
bill I think we got to walk back a
number of years to the last time the Ed
306 rules were attempted to be
changed back then the proposed under the
previous commissioner Jenny Barry
they came forward too I was on Jael car
at the time and the rules which you see
on the sheet I handed out to you where
it says
83631 and then 37.4 Etc all had a one
after them they were modifying these
rules so you had 306
311 if you look in the 306 rule handbook
you have or that was provided you will
see that we went for about I can't
recall the length of time there was a
while a month or two where we had no
minimum uh uh approval standards for
public schools we ran out of time we
have to renew these rules every so often
and the new ones because of some of the
changes there was just a a complete
breakdown in the time frame we ran out
the 180 days and there was a time where
we had absolutely no rules for a couple
weeks there until we got the old rules
reinstated which the that's what we have
right here so the the process there was
a technical advisory put out by the
commissioner back then I have it up at
my chair up there it's something that
maybe we can pass out and hand out at
when we talk about the next bill which
is also the the academic
standards thank you very much
representative luno thank you Mr chair
and and thank you representative lad for
uh for you know put putting this in in
the context of um of what happened what
a decade ago yeah on that what in your
experience uh on jlc car do they have
the ability to um to to extend uh
existing rules um you know
pending additional work that like an
exception uh they are governed by a time
frame we ran out of time back then it's
statute that's when the when the rules
are adopted by
uh by the state
board there's a after it's come to yes
yes and and the technical advisory
explains it pretty well and I think
that's what you need to read and see and
I I do have that available but but I'm
talking specifically about the the the
um expiration of the existing minimum
standards could those be extended by the
by
jelar if they brought
forward I I think I I'm I've been out of
jard now for so I'm a little rusty on
that one I don't want to say something
which is may not be true I know that uh
um Diana
Fenton has probably should have a good
beat on that uh seeing that we've gone
through this in Prior years but I think
that technical advisory would explain
what your asking that I have up front
Okay thank you yeah okay represent what
quickly please thank you Mr I just one
more for my own edification and maybe
those who are listening to this that
that aren't uh totally clear can you
explain a very lay person terms what you
mean when you keep on talking about
rules and rules as regards
this when we pass legislation oftentimes
we pass leg legislation that's at quote
that 30,000 ft
level and then when you have principal
Woodcock up in Conway saying well I want
to know how to implement that down here
and so we give to the department the
State Board the responsibility to try
and get the the stuff that's in the
weeds written out into rules so that you
know how you want to operate and what
you can or can't do uh so the rules are
much like on the federal level we don't
call them rules we call them regulations
on this level we call them all rules
that's basically how you're going to
manage how you're going to operate how
you're going to make this work how are
you going to teach this uh so it's just
giving more information to legislation
on how it's can be it so it won't have
to be interpreted so it it's a little
bit more
objective thank you thank you
CH okay uh thank you very much
representative um I think that brings us
to lunch
and we shall reconvene
at no information
L um we'll reconvene at 12:45 for our
next uh series of bills for the
afternoon thank
you
e
oh yeah good afternoon I I think we're
uh about ready to start um our first
bill of the
afternoon um which is House Bill
1107 relative to Public School
curriculum
Frameworks and and
um chairman lad is uh about ready to
take the hot
seat on that
okay good afternoon my name is Rick lad
I'm a representative from uh haal New
Hampshire Grafton 5 and I'm here today
to speak on hb1
1107 okay even though I left the the
bill up there I I'll go ahead and speak
on it this bill is about curriculum
Frameworks and it's regarding putting
curriculum Frameworks that once were in
legislation which you should have has
come around yet for everybody to
have I'll hold on
then
okay I think everybody has a copy there
right now I'd like you to if you would
please to look first at the sheet which
looks like
this on the back side there's a
double-sided
yeah okay what you see on on that sheet
right there it's if you look at the top
those are the statutes existed in the
state here in
2010 and this part that I have with the
line going the side down the side there
Roman
five tells you a little bit about what
Frameworks
were the curriculum framework shall
present educational
goals broad pedagogical approaches and
strategies for assisting students in
developing development of skills
compasses knowledge called for by by the
academic standards for each area of
Education identified in paragraph 1 and
we've talked about paragraph 1 earlier
today when I referenced you back to the
criteria for the substantive education
the curriculum framework Shall Serve as
a guide and reference to what New
Hampshire students should know and be
able to do in each area of Education the
Frameworks do not establish a Statewide
curriculum it is the responsibility of
local local teachers administrators and
school boards to identify and Implement
approaches best suited for the students
in their communities to acquire the
skills and knowledge included in the
Frameworks to determine the scope
organization's sequence of course
offerings and to choose the methods of
of instruction uh the activities and the
materials to be
used what the legislation I'm proposing
will take that and put it back into
statute now why am I doing that if you
look at the other side of that sheet
you'll find a little bit of language and
and down in the middle of that you'll
see A and B why is this legislation
needed learning frame Frameworks provide
a mechanism for aligning activities and
Educational Learning so that they build
toward a clearly defined end or goal
several times now I've
asked where are the acad mic standards
for mental health where are the academic
standards for social studies and the
response is go look at the
Frameworks well Frameworks are no longer
in statue for one but they do have we do
have Frameworks and you can see on the
right hand side down on the bottom
corner of that page social studies
curriculum Frameworks designed back in
2006 the Arts Frameworks designed in
the health curriculum Frameworks
2003 so I've gone and looked at the
social studies curriculum Frameworks I
see a lot of nice stuff in there but I'm
looking for the academic standards where
are the academic
standards you got to read through that
all thing and assume this is an academic
standard and yet we have responsibility
for oversight of those academic
standards we just talked about that
before
lunch but but then there's other
academic standards we have in
place the Common Core State math
standards they're there the Common Core
State Standards for English language
arts they're there you can look them
right up and the new generation science
standards are there as well you can look
in the in the doe website and find them
but there's just a it's it's
discombobulated it's there's no real
good strong routine for us to find out
what are the the academic
standards and this is important if you
look at the upper right hand side of
that sheet of
paper I have boxed areas curriculum
instruction and
assessment how's a new teacher ever
know what they're going to put in this
curriculum or how they're going to
teach but they sure know that the
Statewide assessment is going to assess
them and do we have a real good strong
understanding that all three of those
areas are
aligned if what happens if the
curriculum it's being taught was way off
to the right or way off to the left
somewhere on that flowchart so then your
instruction may be echoing that
curriculum you identified locally but
the Statewide test may be way over here
and not assessing what has been taught
in the classroom that school district
may receive a real negative ative
achievement
score because we're assessing something
that may not be taught or the curriculum
standards our academic
standards may be very uh not well
described or stated what a child should
know and be able to do some areas we put
clearly in the statute not clearly in
the statute but we put in things like in
social studies topical areas that should
be taught those are really not academic
standards but topical areas so it should
be clear that instruction should somehow
Echo that and the assessment if there
was a social studies assessment
Statewide would have to Echo that um so
I'm I'm real
concerns concerned that Frank Frameworks
support school districts especially
those that do not have curriculum
development staff I've worked in
districts where curriculum is basically
basically designed in a small school
school may only have 150
kids and the curriculum may be that of
the teacher that's been there for
ages and this is what they're
teaching yet the assessment tool might
be totally
different and there's a lot of different
ways of assessing there's formative
tests and summ of the tests while we're
assessing our curriculum is with this
summative
test and it really is not like some of
the old if you look at some of the old
textbooks they usually said a pre- test
a post test chapter test Etc and I'm not
saying I'm infatuated with that process
but you need a a AUM a formative test
which is more Diagnostic in nature which
will help people understand where I got
to go where the child needs to learn
where I have missed the boat where the
child's missed the
boat these Frameworks also offer
instructional approaches which is
important two staff if I were a new
social studies teacher coming into a
school and asked to teach seventh grade
social studies or sixth or fifth
whatever I'd want to have something to
reference is there a guideline there and
that's what these Frameworks do they
provide a guideline for staff on on on
ideas of how to teach what the scope is
going to be of skills what the sequence
is going to be and it's
coordinated and it's coordinated between
all those which are teaching that
studies within that school or School
District so I'm I'm suggesting that we
put the Frameworks back into place and
we use these curriculum Frameworks as a
guide to help instruction and to help
coordinate instruction in the schools
and throughout this state we've missed
the boat we and I in a way want to
apologize too when I came in here I was
all for getting rid of the curriculum
Frameworks I look back over my time and
I say wow maybe it's because I came from
a district that had curriculum directors
and staff there I came from a district
up in Alaska which the curriculum
headquarters of the size of this
building and there was support in just
about every angle of instruction and
curriculum you could believe and right
down into Media
Services and so I felt very comfortable
in in in working there seeing that we
did have a k through 12 scope and
sequence and we had materials in support
which also supported in professional
development along what those academic
standards were came down here and it was
little bit
uh uh discombobulated I'll say the we we
have not upgraded our curriculum
Frameworks in some of these areas since
the early
2000s and yet societ has significantly
Changed History hasn't changed history
is history how we perceive it may change
so um I would like to suggest that we
integrate the curriculum Frameworks put
them back in as uh support of materials
for teachers new teachers teachers
coming in teachers moving between
districts they know what our Statewide
Frameworks are so if I move from Hanover
to havil and that'd be a good move um I
uh I would I would know what the social
study requirements are for the state the
academic standards and we need to make
sure that Within These Frameworks we
identify these are the academic
standards so all are on the same page
thank
you uh thank you representative uh
questions uh yes representative woodcot
thank you chairman I mean chairman
cordelli uh chairman the econic just so
unclear on this now the standards that
you're going to align with the CIA and
the op P so the curriculum instruction
assessment the standards you're talking
about at one point and correctly going
stop on go off scale here one point were
in the legislation they were they were
regulating the law and then they were
taken out the same point everything you
see on the 2010 there Roman 5
has been taken out in terms of
curriculum Frameworks they're no longer
there okay what we're doing is walking
it back to where it was okay may I fall
thank you thank you so the new let's
assume this pass so the new
curriculum uh Frameworks uh scope of
sequence will still be left to the local
education commun this the Frameworks of
what you want youngsters to learn I
that's going to be established by
whom if you take the curriculum
Frameworks which we are using right now
we are using them for social studies
we're using them for health we're using
them for the Arts those were developed
by a task force of folks that came from
the school districts expertise in these
subject areas people from doe came
together they wrote These Frameworks
okay which then were put in place may I
just one more thank you so just falling
the same piece so if this passed and
there were new Frameworks required um
like's say upgrading what these have to
be
okay it won't be legislatively assigned
who is going to create the framework
that be up to the commissioner or up to
doe to decide how they going to do that
yeah that that would not be a
responsibility of the legislature and
you need no rules to do that that would
be something which done just like we did
in the past okay the Committees would be
set up through the department all right
so okay all right thank you thank you Mr
chair any further questions represent
know what year were the curriculum
Frameworks removed from
statute sorry I forgot to um
they it was just around 2011
2010 because I went you can you can find
out by looking at the law books which
are in there in the committee room my
question I can't remember maybe somebody
behind me might recall that but it had
to be
back uh several years after I it was
probably most likely the end of 201 fy11
I think was the end of
the of the Frameworks being in
statute so statute refu ref referred you
to those curriculum guidelines but also
to the academic standards when I've gone
to doe asking where can I find the
academic standards for social studies
they say look at the
Frameworks well technically we don't
have any Frameworks that we do those
were approved by the state board but if
we were to make new
ones you should have legislation which
supports the need for Frameworks and
what the purpose
is yes representative
Lake why did they get rid of the
Frameworks because there were novices
like me that came in and said we don't
need them because that can be done
locally thank you yeah representative
dry thank you representative cardelli
um the 2010 talks about the curriculum
Frameworks the current edition of 193
e2a talks about minimum standards for
public approval and your proposal has
minimum standard standards for public
approval and curriculum Frameworks can
you explain to me the difference Min
minimum standards for public school
approval are not academic standards
supposedly there's two remember when we
talked about the legislative oversight
Committee in the last bill we have
responsibility for reviewing and having
oversight of the academic
standards we don't have that Authority
we would if that first bill was passed
had the responsibility for the uh
minimum standards for public school
approval they are different and so when
they say look at the minimum standards
of public school approval to find those
academic standards it's just
it's the
minimum it's confusing and it's more
than confusing it's disc combobulated
it's uh you know it's saying well
because you can't find it there it's
over there but you don't have the
authority to look at over there you can
look over here at the academic standards
it it it's it's uh we need to get this
process streamlined so it's well
understood by people out in the field as
well just follow up follow up okay so in
in your proposal is curriculum
Frameworks kind of an equivalent of
academic
standards no okay and why I say that is
that the curriculum Frameworks are
guidelines on how you might conduct your
curriculum they are also guidelines that
show scope and sequence of how these
standards are in how you you follow
these standards with skills and
knowledge through the grades so the
academic standards that's why I said
over and over I don't believe the way
the curriculum Frameworks are written
really identify by the academic
standards what are the academic
standards I'll ask you right now what
are the academic standards for social
studies what are the academic standards
for for art what are the academic
standards for um any subject that's in
the adequacy area there now you can tell
me that by math and English and language
arts because those are those are
established we just took the Common Core
State Standards for
that but the other area
I can't tell you if you ask me
specifically Rick tell me what the
academic standards of social studies are
civics government economics geography
history I couldn't tell you and I could
not at this point tell you where to go
look for
them if anybody here knows where let me
know uh represent
Tanner thank you um I'm just looking
back in the the law book and in
2016 uh the word minimum standards were
was substituted for curriculum
Frameworks okay with 16 then thank
you page 56 see that's at the same time
we
removed the Statewide assessment used to
have social studies Incorporated in it
but we were never giving a Statewide
assessment on social studies so then we
said yes it's still part of the
Statewide Assessment program but we'll
be conducted by the local school
district thank you very much Mr chair um
so the the the question sort of goes
goes back to not the U well it's the
language that you've got in the in the
bill but also um I think it it pulls
from the um the language that you've had
in the
2020 law book uh where it says uh uh the
uh well in the bill bill it's on line 10
and 11 lines 10 11 the curriculum
framework sh Shall Serve as a guide and
reference to what New Hampshire students
should know and be able to do in each
area of curc and then down at the bottom
of page one in the bill it says it
defines curriculum framework differently
it's not about should know and be able
to do it talks about um uh that serves
as a guide for
instruction so I guess the question is
is that is it are we setting a
consistent definition for curriculum
framework um in here is it an is it an
assessment tool or is it an
instruction
tool the curriculum guides are
curriculum
oriented and from your curriculum you
have your
instruction
the assessment is in a separate area of
Statute
um so that's a local concern yeah right
so so thanks a followup so so so then it
goes back to the the language that that
that was historically in the in the
statute that you've got in on lines 101
sorry 11
1213 on page one
um that the framework Shall Serve as a
guide and reference to what New
Hampshire sure students should know and
be able to do or is it something
different than that it's really a guide
for
instruction I think as a guide for
curriculum how you how you
instruct is totally a a local issue you
might be doing it through team teaching
you may be doing it you know instruction
in the classroom looking from classroom
a to classroom B instruction might be
totally different but the curriculum
should parallel the academic standards
and the established curriculum for that
District you know all districts are not
going to be teaching a subject at the
same grade level you may in a school
teach us history at one grade level
another one at another grade level but
we as a state want to assess everything
at this particular Focus
time some districts kids are being being
assessed on something they haven't
learned yet and may be learning it the
next year that does occur in this
state okay thanks yeah any further
questions I seeing none thank you very
much thank you and I believe um
Christine one other thing oh yes I did
pass the technical advisory out to you
so you can read where we went astray on
those rules back in
2015 thank you uh Christine
Downey thank you again committee um
Christine Downing uh Goan New Hampshire
um I want to applaud representative lad
for bringing this uh Bill to light with
the curriculum Frameworks one of this
this has um connections right now to the
ongoing work around the 306 especially
in the content area that I spoke about
earlier those are the sections um 31
through 48 um playing out all the
different areas that representative lad
also spoke about as an adequate
education um I just wanted to give a
little I've been 17 years now in
curriculum instruction and assessment
that's that's kind of been my livelihood
in public school so I want to just help
to clarify the idea of the curriculum
Frameworks in terms of our minimum
School approval standards and our
academic standards um I was part of I
really date myself now in terms of age
um in
1998 I was actually part of the team
that did the second revision the second
update to the um kada 12 Mathematics
Curriculum framework at the state that
lived until about 2006 2007 and so from
a field perspective when did the
curriculum framework start to Fall Away
honestly they started to fall away with
the movement around the Common Core
State Standards and National organiz
ations trying to get all 50 states on
board um to deliver consistency in our
academic areas so I would just add that
insight to this conversation the other
thing I would add is that the minimum
School approval standards are really um
aligned to adequate education that
that's their goal their purpose is to
really um specify how we meet that
adequate education and everything
spelled out in that RSA
193e um from content to operational
perspectives so there's one part of it
the academic standards that are also
listed in there really simply just get
at the basic knowledge and skills that
we want in the content areas for the um
for our students now where do the
curriculum Frameworks come in they are a
combination of giving suggested best
practices in instructional and
assessment um and we did used to have
that let me give you an example to maybe
help clarify for example the Common Core
State Standards which we have adopted
and you can find
some of our academic standards
representative lad is completely correct
here that we do not have academic
standards for all the areas listed
inadequate education the most recent is
personal finance literacy there are no
academic standards currently to back
that up um and so academic standards I'm
going to use math for example that's my
old wheelhouse the Common Core State
Standards and Mathematics for example
will prescribe very specific mathematics
skills and Concepts we want kids to know
for example you know by the end of third
grade we want students to be able for
example to multiply double in triple
digit numbers right so it it'll say
something specific to that but it really
none of these academic standards really
go to the level of best practices in in
terms of instruction so one of the
debates we're in the middle of with the
306 currently is um what is contained in
the minimum School approval standard
under our content areas does that belong
in the minimum School approval standards
or does it belong in the academic
standards and I'll give you an example
just here bear with me for a second um
but what with this bill what I'm really
encouraged by if you haven't guessed I
fully support the bill but what this
bill would do for us it would put the
bridge between okay this is logistically
what we have to do we have to provide a
k through 12 Mathematics Curriculum our
schools that's part of adequate
education here are the skills and
Concepts from the Common Core that we
need to do but what are we going to set
as the ground floor for consistent
instructional and assessment practices
for our schools again that's local
control but we want to give some
guidance on that here's an example of
what I made and this is where we're
debating and why we're running these
educator review section sessions in
February and March for example right now
under the mathematics section of the 306
rules it says um the local school board
shall uh require that a mathematics
program in each Elementary School um
includes or provides and and here's what
it says opportunities for authentic
tasks that promote student
decision-making and questioning
encourage students to develop unique
problem solving strategies while
allowing students to defend their
strategies and results planned
activities that promote developmental
math concepts from the concrete to the
represent representational and finally
to the abstract level and and there's
more statement like that that go on
where we as a 306 group have been
struggling between is should this live
in the minimum School approval standards
should it live in the academic stands
and what we've come to realize is it
should go back into our curriculum
Frameworks that we used to have back in
the late 90s and I would say right up
till about 20102 which is when we became
Common Core um so I think this this bill
is super important I just want to point
out that some some feedback that I
received from the Educators is is this
that actually in the high school section
of the 306 rules right now it says under
Section U this is
30627 school districts shall develop
course Competency Based on New Hampshire
academic standards where appable for all
course offerings school districts may
use State model course competencies to
develop minimum course competencies just
like representative lad has said where
is that the field is saying we we want
guidance in that and what they're
further saying is um they said New
Hampshire Public Schools this was a
quote from some a group that worked on
it New Hampshire Public Schools would be
better served by a commitment from New
Hampshire education dep Department to
articulate and publish State academic
standards and model competencies in all
content areas consistent feedback
through these review sessions indicate
public schools have been waiting for
over a decade for the state to provide
consistent graduation competencies with
clear State academic standards and
graduation competencies outlined there's
a strong support that Competency Based
education can move forward consistently
in our Public Schools so I'm a strong
supporter of this um bill I think
curriculum Frameworks is that missing
link between what we say we have to do
for an adequate education what our
national most of our acade State
academic standards are just linked to
National standards currently what what
they say um is the body of Knowledge and
Skills in those content areas to okay
now how do we make that operationally
happen for our students so strong
supporter of this bill and again commend
representative lad and for those that
worked on it thank you thank you any
questions from the
committee uh representative casken thank
you uh thank you Mr chair and thank you
uh Christine for um being so uh
enlightening um so yeah I've been around
long enough to work with Frameworks and
whatnot and I question you know this
pendulum push as we've experienced it
and it was the most helpful document so
I absolutely support going back to a
Frameworks and then Common Core came
very
controversial then we had common core
for Math and
Ela um but my question is do you think
or do you see Competency Based
education sort of throwing a wrench in
all of this in a different light or is
there no connection between that because
that was another wave yes I I think I'm
actually I see Competency Based
education as being our broad umbrella
that pulls this alog together it's the
glue because you really need solid you
need a couple of things to build your
competencies you need solid academic
standards that are going to outline that
that content Knowledge and Skills right
but then you also need that guidance in
the instructional part of it the best
practices of instruction to really build
that competency strong because remember
competencies are really about three
things it's one what acquisition of
Knowledge and Skills do I want you to
have two how do I want you as a student
to make meaning of that Knowledge and
Skills and here's the third one and this
really ties to what the curriculum
Frameworks could do is how do you
transfer and apply that learning right
and I I think the curriculum Frameworks
you know if we do these right and we get
them back and we get just how they were
originally built with Educators at the
table we can build excellent curriculum
Frameworks that honestly you know part
of the debate the 306 has had around
these content areas the team has had is
where do we don't want to lose these
things because right now at least they
are giving some guidance to the field
but if we pull them out there's nothing
there because right now it's you have
kind of R down 306 rules but you have
these these academic standards that are
really checklist of things and we don't
want to go back that way and when I saw
this bill I was like th this is the
missing piece of what we need to really
put this all
together any further questions I see
none thank you very
much and that will close the hearing on
uh House Bill
1107 and uh in a moment after I confer
with the chair we'll move on to uh HB
year
chairman lad I'd like to ask a question
please that I couldn't ask at the end of
our discussion there I didn't on on the
on the one you just were we're off we're
off that one right now well this is the
sequel to it I mean and I couldn't ask
the question so when do I get to ask
question that's my question do it what
we're going to do right
now we are going into executive
session
and
give
toell thank you um Mr chairman um we
were interested in um executing House
Bill
1163 relative to review of public school
minimum standards by the Legislative
oversight commission this is the bill we
heard uh just before lunch I'll make a
motion to OTP L second
second any further further discussion by
either no no okay any discussion by
anyone on the
committee seen
none um Madam
clerk Vice chairman Cordell yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative corello yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes representative wock
yes representative Hall yes
representative Bon yes representative
cascaden yes representative Damon yes
chairman lad yes 16 yays thank you Zer y
go ahead any consent
okay great thank you okay I'll take the
gavel back and I will explain with
1163 the one we just did we're going to
try and tie this bridge a little bit
better with curriculum and
instruction and so we're going to take a
little bit more time on this work on it
um we feel that this is also a sequel to
what we just did um this is really
foundational to how we're going to
develop the learning in our schools and
improve it in our schools through the
properly identifying and structuring the
minimum standards Public School approval
in conjunction with academic
standards so the Frameworks are a local
state Affair and so we'll move in that
direction with the those Frameworks but
we're going to take a little bit more
time to discuss it and work up perhaps
some amending
language so with that we'll go on to the
next bill on the docket here for
today want to let Oliver ask his
question oh Oliver had a question yes
you had a question on the
Frameworks representative leus and I
have been discussing the question of
math education for quite some time and
we've been wondering at some point
whether or not we need to introduce the
idea
of how we teach people math education
how we teach them math how we teach them
to think about math and that based on
some of our personal experiences we had
experience places where they teach you
the thinking of math not just the
finding of answers to problems okay
that's that's down the road ways as far
as you know dealing with with
mathematics as it content area right now
we really do need to get on because
we're on a tight line here in terms of
time I'm out of here myself and
about 20 25 minutes uh for another
meeting at Grant State College so um I'd
like to get on to the next bill dealing
with
1066 um relative to the graduation
requirement of filing a free application
for federal student aid FAFSA and I'd
like to welcome representative Noble the
sponsor of the bill good afternoon
chairman lad and fellow members of the
committee my name is Kristen Noble and I
represent Hillsboro District 2 the town
of Bedford HB 1066 would repeal the ffs
of graduation requirement found under
RSA 19 193 col
26- it would be replaced with a
Schoolboard policy requiring districts
to provide information to students and
their parents about the free application
for federal student
aid from what I understand the goal
behind this graduation requirement was
to get more kids to go to college that
our FAFSA completion rate in the state
of New Hampshire is too low and with
this mandate students May potentially
see that they can afford college and
decide to
go the truth is it's not as simple as
everyone fill out this form and see if
you qualify and then you'll know if you
want to go to
college it's a lengthy multi-step
process that first starts with knowing
that you want to attend college then you
research schools visit schools apply to
school and usually at that point you
fill out the
FAFSA you must choose at least one
school to send your financial
information to in order to see if you
qualify for Aid you cannot complete the
form without it so you're going through
all of those other steps
first so here's a few reasons to support
the repeal of this graduation
requirement this is government overreach
it is a privacy issue the government may
have your data already but these schools
do not and the state shouldn't be trying
to force families into sharing their
private financial
information it is sending a message me
to students that college is the best
path and that is not true for everyone I
heard from a public high school teacher
in support of this bill he told me that
he had a student who did an
apprenticeship apprenticeship before he
even graduated he helped encourage his
student to follow that Path college is
not for everyone and that's perfectly
okay we should be trusting the
Professionals in our schools to provide
guidance for those students who want to
attend college they know the kids and if
they have low-income students who may
potentially qualify for the pel grant
they will absolutely steer them in the
direction of choosing a school and
filling out the
FAFSA if a student has the desire to go
to college and cannot afford to pay out
of pocket that family is most likely
filling out the FAFSA without it being a
requirement for graduation
for most students FAFSA does not provide
a complete picture of
affordability a high school diploma
should not be tied to anything but
academics and not if their parents
filled out a government
form
lastly this is not a real requirement
parents can fill out a waiver or they
can do nothing at all in their child
will still graduate
it's a law that cannot be enforced
therefore it makes sense to repeal it
and replace it with the Schoolboard
policy that requires districts to
provide information to students and
parents but largely leaves that process
up to them by respecting local
control so we were 1010 on this in the
spring but outside of this room this is
not a partisan issue I found that out
this weekend when I heard from
constituents who generally do not agree
with me on anything
else but they do on
this I showed you in the spring over 20
superintendents that are on board with
repealing this is a bipartisan this bill
is bipartisan it's sensible and I ask
you to support it thank you thank you
very much representative are there any
questions yes repres
Hall thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question um
you said that it's a um an R it cannot
be enforced but you said and as we know
that it has a waiver so how can it not
be enforced if if you don't want to do
it you just fill out the waiver I mean
they can keep track of whether the
school districts can I think keep track
of whether they're you know they got the
paperwork or they don't yes or no or
thank you for the representative Hall
even if they don't get a waiver they
they can't stop the child from
graduating so they they could they could
chase after the parents and if they
don't get any answer at all the the
child is still going to
graduate further
questions represent luno thank you very
much Mr chair and thank you very much
representative for bringing this forward
I was wondering if you could elaborate a
little bit more about what your
constituents um concerns are over the
existing um um statute and um and what
they like best about
this uh I heard the word overreach a lot
um and and not from Republicans also
from
Democrats and they also consider it to
be a privacy
issue follow follow yes go ahead um and
so so when when talking about overreach
and in in view of the fact that a simple
waiver um uh prepared by either the the
family or by the principal can um can
release the
student of this as a graduation
requirement um were they aware of of
that those those Provisions in the
current law yes they're
aware would you like me to elaborate on
that I mean they're they're aware of it
but it's still still seen as like a bad
precedent I mean what else are we going
to tie to graduation besides
academics you know this could this could
go
further represent Bon thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question um
I when this you came up at the in the
spring it was the first time it hadn't
actually been instituted yet so the
first time would have been this past
June so do we have any data available on
what really happened schoolwide I mean I
you're giving anecdotal data but I mean
from the superintendent involved I see
that there's a letter here but what what
happened do we
have um I I think that there is the
school administrators Association here
that might be able to answer that a
little bit better or even the school
board Administration and we also have
representative Raymond here as well who
is on the nationa school board so she
might be able to answer that a little
bit better than
me representative
petel thank you Mr chair um thank you
representative Noble on line seven of
the bill it says um well it starts on
line
six pupils eligible for graduation shall
have the opportunity to receive
information on how to properly complete
are there students now who don't have
the opportunity to receive this
information I mean it would seem to me
that if somebody wanted to go to college
they would be seeking out the
information they needed in order to
apply to a college thank you for the
question representative Pell um as far
as I know the school districts are
pretty much following what's what's in
here now so they have their information
nights and that kind of thing they
provide information to students and
parents currently and have been doing
that for quite some time as far as I
know yes go
ahead so we're not just
repealing legislation we're replacing it
with maybe unnecessary legislation
because they're already doing
this what they're already doing
what your bill
proposes so do they need even your bill
why wouldn't we just completely repeal
the
RSA thank you for the
question
um
I I would say most of the schools are
doing it I don't know if we know if all
of them are so this does put this in
place
F further
questions not seeing it thank you very
much we have at this time four cards up
here on this are there any other folks
out in the crowd that are going to want
to speak on this that haven't submitted
a card if so we'll get you in
here was there any technical support
from
the school uh administrators Association
is Mark McAn
here thank
you does do
you okay so afterwards would you fill
out one of these things for us please
thank
[Music]
you uh certainly uh and thank you Mr
chairman thank you committee for the
question uh in regard to the fast for
law the understanding last year is that
it was a requirement for schools and
just as the representative spoke to uh
for many schools that didn't necessarily
fit and just of others have spoken about
schools do make FASA a that opportunity
aware for their students who may benefit
from that and the fact that it was a
requirement did feel like it was pretty
heavy-handed to some school dist
districts um and school districts are
making that available uh to their
students and um I believe repealing that
and replacing it with language that
makes it a priority certainly makes
sense in applicability in the
field are there any questions from the
committee yes represent luno thanks
thanks very much Mr chair so um so are
are you aware of um of what um Glen how
how FAFSA completion rates have changed
in other states that have adopted the
law that's currently on the books in New
Hampshire I I have not done that
research okay so so just to set the
stage for a follow-up question um uh
Texas adopted um our what what we now
have as current law back I think in 2018
or
2019 and they are now ranked um number
one in the nation um for year-over-year
change in FAFSA completion in fact their
um their rate of completion is
56% um which is above the national rate
of
46% and um and I guess my question to
you would
be do do you believe that um that uh
that if more students complete the FAFSA
then more students will um will will
will Ser will take a serious look at
higher education
opportunities yeah I think there's
probably a very strong likelihood that
there would be a correlation there I
think that we could certainly bring more
awareness to FASA in how that can
benefit folks uh in other ways we can
lift the importance of that and just
uh differently than making it a
legislative requirement I think there
are ways to highlight that working with
other organizations and I know that the
superintendent Association would be
willing to be part of lifting the
importance of the FASA okay thank
you represent
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um which is about the
end part of the proposed Bill lines 28
29 which in addition to what has already
been discussed would repeal the report
on completion of the f ASA and I'm
interested in your opinion on if we're
not tracking how many students are
completing it regardless of whether it's
required or not how do we know how we're
doing um again this is I in study for
this uh question but I can tell you that
there are um percentages and data
relative to Fasto requirements and
completion that existed prior to this so
I would say that we rely on those same
metrics to determine whether or not
there's been enough IC in the number of
people that are uh completing the
FAA is that data that you're referring
to compiled by the federal government
from how many are submitted or do we
know where they I'm going to look over
here at representative luno as he just
spoke to the percentage so I'm assuming
that you grabbed that from um that data
from a source where you referenced
Texas um so did you compare the New
Hampshire average to that or was just
national average it was just Texas
gotcha okay so I think that's certainly
something that we could talk to our
friends in higher education with as well
and and and since I was directed in uh
in that um uh the the New Hampshire
requirement I believe either just went
active this prior school year or it's
this is it was it this prior school year
I I believe it's this school year this
school year so it prior yeah this excuse
me this prior school year the one so the
the the class graduating in June of
2023 three so four four so so has not
even gone active yet so we don't have
any data to compare about how the law
has affected um and I I don't know
honestly how you would compare before
and after if there is not an accurate
accounting of whether or not there's a
baseline well there there there is in
the in the US Ed website you actually
have state byst state and District
District by District um number of
students who have completed the pass and
that was I guess that was my response to
representative Damon is that there are
metrics out there so whether or not
school districts are filing a report
with the Department of Education as a
result of this legislation there is data
out there that shows the completion rate
of the fasta I think that was your
question to me representative
representative Belcher thank you Mr
chair and thank you for your testimony
um very simple question would it
surprise
you that under a circumstance where the
government was no longer forcing
somebody to do something but allowing
them to use their choice of whether or
not to do it and providing that choice
that completion numbers might go down a
little um I mean I guess anything's
possible so I that's a pretty open-ended
question
so any further
questions thank you very much for your
testimony thank you
y um representative
Raymond thank
you yeah pres much more oh it's oh it
left on sorry confused by the bot in um
so I'm Heather Raymond I'm
representative for Hillsboro um District
5 that's NASA um in addition to being a
State Rep I'm also on the national board
of education and I've been on the board
of education for the last six years I
have to count backwards it's been a
while um and I'm a parent of a high
schooler and a middle schooler in ASA um
so um when I was approached on this bill
um about being a co-sponsor I was
hesitant because I don't agree with a
lot of things um with some of the
sponsors but we do agree on this I sat
down and um mat with our superintendent
our guidance team um and our assistant
superintendent um in nsha um and you'll
notice the letter I passed out that our
superintendent is one of the ones that
wrote the letter um in nasua our
concerns about the FASA requirement are
significantly different than the
concerns that I think some of the other
sponsors have about this um we're not so
much concerned about the fact that the
government is collecting information
because a lot of this information is
stuff that people are already submitting
to the IRS every year when they file
their taxes um our concern is about um
how this is going to impact our students
and whether or not um it is appropriate
to restrict their access to their
diploma based on whether or not their
parent or Guardian has completed a form
whether it be the FAFSA form or the
waiver form so just some some
information about NASA nasua launch
launched um a free Chromebook free a
Chromebook program for our students last
year we started with high schools and
then we expanded it to the Middle School
this year all parents or Guardians need
to do is sign the Chromebook agreement
which we sent home with every student
last year and this year and in exchange
for that each student gets a Chromebook
that they keep with them for the
remainder of their time at school
there's no charge for this if it breaks
they bring it back we fix it um because
we use so much online curriculum we
wanted our students to have access to
that at all times nashaa has about 5,000
students in the secondary level a little
bit more of those 5,000 students 300
still in January have not been able to
obtain a signature from a parent or
Guardian to get a free Chromebook these
are 300 students who don't don't have a
trusted adult that can sign a form to
give them a device to help them with
their
education now we've done a lot of
Outreach there are phone calls home
there are emails home there are letters
home we've sent guidance counselers out
to homes and at this point we've
resigned ourselves to Simply having
these students pick up their issued
Chromebook when they get to school and
then leave it when they leave for the
end of the day um our con concern and
the concern of our guidance department
is that this requirement of a signature
and it's not just a signature on the
waiver form because really we're asking
people to go to the website and fill out
the FAFSA it's going to leave these kids
our most vulnerable
kids with without with with a without a
path to getting their diploma right
these are kids who are showing up to
school every day they're doing their
part and they don't have a trusted adult
who's willing to do their part and it's
just it simply feels like an inequity
for us to then say you didn't meet the
prerequisites for your diploma that you
just worked four years to
earn we're really really concerned about
that um if we hadn't launched the
Chromebook program I don't know that we
would have the same concern um but we
know that it's very difficult the other
issue that we've noticed in NWA um which
I I just want to point out to the
committee and it even if you were to
pass this bill I don't think it could
change in time for this graduation
because the bill would take in effect in
July this year the federal government
redid the FAFSA it was supposed to come
out in October it was released on
Friday and only to some people there are
still people in my district who cannot
who want to do the FAFSA who have kids
who are ready to go to college who
cannot get on to fill out the FAFSA our
school file a FAFSA night that we
sponsor and our guidance counselors do
like an information session is on uh
January 18th it works best if parents
have filled out part because there's a
two parts to the FAA the parents have to
sign something and then the kids have to
fill out some stuff it works best if the
parents have done that but we're
actually talking about in The District
delaying our file of fafs a night
another few weeks to give people the
opportunity to go on and do it um and so
you know the the the Crux of it is is
that we Rec recogniz that um going to
college is important we also recognize
that some trade schools accept the FAFSA
in Nashville we have one of the largest
CTE programs we have 1300 students in 16
programs and over 40 classes these kids
may or may not choose to go to college
but we really don't want to hang on to a
diploma that a child has earned because
of a lack of a signature from a parent
or a guardian
so thank you very much representative
Hall thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question can you just tell
me the date that this letter was written
that you you said you were I don't know
I met with the
superintendent um I know the the last
week in August and he had had this and
said hey I had I I had sent this to it
so I'm not sure the date that this was
sent originally I just noticed names on
here they're not really superintendents
anymore so I'm thinking this for this
was probably submitted before black bill
so these folks haven't lived through the
new legislation no and and it hasn't
taken effect so the the students who
will be impacted in my district are the
students graduating this year so our
current
seniors okay thank you representative
luno thank you very much Mr chair and
thanks very much for uh for joining us
so um so is is the um are the princip
at um at the nsha high schools I guess
um not interested in I mean I I guess
what I'm saying is are are are they are
they planning to resist um uh providing
you know a waiver that attests to the
the schools or or I mean are they
unwilling to do that because it seems
pretty simple in the state law at the
end of the day can wave it all right at
the end of day I don't believe that um
our principles will allow students who
have earned the diploma to not get their
diploma right I think at the end of the
day we're going to do what we need to do
however the question is is there a
penalty for that I don't know they asked
me I don't know the answer so um but I
don't know that that is I understand
that that's an opt out I don't know that
that's in keeping with the spirit of the
idea of making everyone follow FAA if we
know that the principal can just wave
you off well then how is that impacting
you know how is that benefiting our
students through through higher
completion rates of the I guess my my
other question then having met with the
administrative team and the guidance
team is how is higher completion rates
of a FAFSA benefiting our students at
large through personal financial
literacy and understanding what the cost
of college and what their what their
access to higher education may
be thank you any further questions
see none thank you very much
representative and next representative
uh is representative
dry thank you Mr chairman and thank you
committee uh for the record I'm
representative Margaret dry I represent
Sullivan County district 7 and I'm a
co-sponsor of this
bill the very first call
legislatively that I got 2024 was from a
former member member um of the school
district down in Manchester uh she's a
former neighbor and uh she called to say
what the heck what's this FAFSA thing
that everybody had to fill out is this
new and I told her it was and she said
hm I have a long history as a teacher of
US history and Civics to English
language learn ERS and here's what I
have to say about it she said this is an
extra burden it's unnecessary because
anybody can get help from a guidance
counselor if they need help to fill out
a FAFSA form and it's intrusive a lot of
the families she works with don't want
their personal information passed around
or
disclosed she wondered why we were
making state law about a federal form
for a state education requirement
graduation requirement and finally she
just said it's just another thing for
teachers and principles to have to do
and I tend to agree with
her in my own
experience recently representative Hall
and I were on the commission to study
tourism and Hospitality education in New
Hampshire from the very beginning of the
hearings the people that were in the
tourism and hospitality industry
stressed how hard it was with this major
hurdle they had to overcome to get
staff with the idea that going to a tech
school or learning a trade instead of
going to college was somehow an inferior
career choice it isn't but making
filling out of FAFSA for
graduation seems to perpetuate that
idea it's something that they're
fighting all the time and one of the
major recommendations of the commission
was to educate people that there are
great career choices that can be made
and but it don't necessarily involve
College though this was a good
intentioned
legislation I think that there are
easier ways to get to the same place
that we're going and I ask you to
support this
Bill thank you representative questions
from the committee seen none thank you
very
much uh next is uh Miss anarie
Banfield you thank you I'm in support of
this bill um I think as a parental
rights advocate in New Hampshire the
feedback that I'm getting is um first of
all
it's the opt-in opt out kind of approach
to the fasta that you have to opt out of
it versus opt in and whenever that's uh
a situation and you have to file a
waiver parents are saying uh you know my
kid's going to come home I have to you
have to fill out the fasta or I don't
get to graduate and then they're filling
out the fasta with no intention of ever
really needing to do this maybe their
child's going to a trade school or
something uh we know that
from prior testimony that a lot of times
these forums are never get to the
parents or the parents aren't familiar
with it or they have no idea that this
is required or that they can opt out of
it so I think the the problem presents
itself I think we've covered that I
don't want to repeat that but those are
the kinds of comments that I'm getting
back from parents I know that that was
brought up by representative Luna what
kind of feedback are you getting um you
know how many people will this impact in
this State you have a fraction of of
students who go on to college many of
them don't uh why are they required to
fill this out because it's it's almost
coercive in a way if you don't fill this
out your child's not graduating oh but
we'll go ahead and let you have a waiver
it's almost a coercive kind of approach
to trying to get these kids to fill out
of FASA uh parents that you know the
Privacy was brought up yes the IRS is
getting this but this is going to
another agency what I heard mainly is
not so much that the government's
collecting this information it's more
about you're sending it to another
agency it has where there's an
opportunity for a data breach that's
really I think what what most concerns
people is that you know is will there
ever be a data breach um so those are
the concerns I just wanted to share that
with you thank you questions from the
committee see none thank
you uh Christiana
Thornton
I was going to say good morning but I
guess it's actually afternoon um my name
is Christiana thoron I'm president of
granite Advance uh formerly known as New
Hampshire higher education assistance
Foundation um we're a Statewide
nonprofit organization that's been
working in the state um with students
and families since the 1960s um and our
primary goal is to help students and
families as they prepare for um College
and Career pathways and so we haven't
taken a position on the bill but I
thought if people had questions
specifically about the FASA um what the
current sort of requirements are um you
know we our organization provides
resources to help students families and
school counselors to really understand
what the FAFSA is um what the timelines
are for getting it you know uh completed
and submitted to um federal student aid
um I will say that when we've been doing
this work um for many many years prior
to the law being passed um when the law
passed I think we saw it as our
responsibility to really ensure that
school counselors and parents and
students understood that there was now a
requirement um and so we've really spent
the past I guess maybe year and a half
or so bringing together stakeholders to
make sure that as long as the law um
remains in effect that there is an
understanding of what that requirement
is and making sure that are supports to
help those students to complete those
forms um and so that's to answer the
questions earlier um they were correct
that the requirement um comes into place
for this Academic Year um and so at this
point in time this process is just
starting um so in terms of what the
outcomes are I think we don't really
know that um yet as it was indicated the
FAFSA opened up um in a I guess I would
say a um not temporary um but a there's
a new form um which has sought to reduce
the number of questions on the Fafa it
used to be over a 100 questions they've
really tried to minimize that to make it
a little bit easier for students to
complete um that new form became
available uh last week and I think over
the next month students will start that
process um of completing and we'll know
better then I think as to what whether
or not you know what is that impact in
that correlation um the information
about FAFSA um in terms of the number of
students that complete you can go to
federal student aid um there is a Fafa
tracker there and you should be able to
see what the completion rates are both
um here in New Hampshire and across the
country thank you very much uh
representative
peternell thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question can you tell me
how long a facet takes to
complete so that I think is the so this
is a question that is in flux now so
there was Congressional well Congress
passed a piece of legislation that
reduced it from 100 over 100 questions
um I think it's now down to like 35 or
so it's they've reduced it quite a bit
how long that takes I'm not sure yet
because the first people just started
completing it last week um so I think
they the goal is that it's going to
minimize the amount of time that it
takes but I think how long that is we're
not quite sure follow up how long did it
take in the old way the old test or the
I'm sorry the old
form I have not personally completed it
yet I would say it probably depends on
the complexity of your financial
situation um and there before you had
there wasn't a feeder from IRS
information into the FASA and so one of
the improvements they've made is that
actually you don't have to re input the
information that you've submitted to the
IRS that it actually is integrated um so
I think that should say some significant
amount of time I think one thing I I had
failed to mention um was just to
recognize you know a couple of things
that have been stated are absolutely
true we do know that um the in the
states that have had a requirement they
have increased their completion of the
FASA which in turn there is a
correlation between the number of
students that ultimately go on to
college um I will also say I think the
challenge has been that we are very well
aware um that this has been a burden on
um School administrators and school
counselors and so our job has been to
really not necessarily take any position
on it but to say okay how can we support
these students in making sure that the
school counselors are aware of the
requirement and give them as many tools
and best practices to make it as
seamless as possible um so I guess I
would say I think all of the testimony
today is you know I think there's
there's truth in all of it and I think
it's sort of been an evolution um I
don't personally know like what is the
right answer I think everybody has sort
of indicated what some of the challenges
are but also there is a tremendous
benefit too and I think that's your role
is to weigh those
components thank you representative luno
thank you very much Mr chair and thank
you very much Miss Thorton for uh for
joining us this afternoon could you talk
tell us a little bit about um uh how the
FAFSA connects families with with pel
Grant
and um and potentially access to to
fully paid Community College right so in
order for a student to
receive any type of federal or state
financial aid um you have to have
completed the Fafa um and so if you are
going to get um a free um like a pel
grant which would cover significant
costs associated with either Community
College um or you know for your
institution you have to have completed
the fasta so I think one of the
challenges um that we do see from time
to time is a student often time I have a
son who's a junior in high school um
getting his attention to focus on like
hey you need to you know what are your
plans what do you want to pursue um can
be a challenge and you have situations
where maybe a student isn't really
thinking about whether or not college or
career um Pursuit at a college is an
option for them until later on in the
year that puts them in a position of
losing out on potential Financial
Resources to be able to support that
pathway and so I think the thought
behind this initially really was making
sure that even if a student decided not
to pursue higher education if they had
completed the paperwork and they made a
last minute decision in let's say May or
June that in fact they do want to go and
start going to a local community commity
College they would have that form
completed and they would be eligible for
that financial aid so that's I think I
think that is sort of the the part to
this that makes it challenging is if a
student hasn't completed it they're not
entitled to the aid um and that goes
with some of those state require The
Limited State funds we do have in order
to be able to benefit from those you
have to complete that
form sure so thanks and this is this is
a test going back to last Friday oh boy
um do uh do you recall what Chancellor
Rubenstein said with respect to the
percentage of students at New Hampshire
community colleges that are there on a
pel gram I don't recall that number but
I expect you do yeah it's it's it's a
it's it's it's a significant number it's
uh it's north of 25% of all of all
community college students are receiving
pel any further questions uh
representative
forward I know we've been talking a lot
about college but I want to follow up on
what was just asked you by my colleague
aren't there s significant numbers of
programs that require the FAA for
funding that is not for college per se
but for career paths that may differ
from
college I I think
um to representative Leno's point I
think a lot of the programs through the
community college system um that are
preparing students for career pathways
are likely those that would be eligible
for some type of federal
assistance and therefore in order to
qualify that you would have to have
completed the F correct yeah thank you
represent
belshire thank you Mr chair and thank
you for being here to provide this
information can ask a bit of a tough
question I'm not sure if you have the
answer but it's worthwhile if we can
find out try um do you happen to know um
of students who complete the FAFSA and
go on to
college do you know what percentage on
average of their costs are taken care of
by grants that do not have to be repaid
versus what percentage is taken in
loans uh that do have to be repaid yeah
unfortunately that's not a question I'm
prepared to answer I could certainly try
to see if there's a resource that would
have would tie those factors together
but I'm not like not on the top of my
head sure thank you was there any
further questions of represent Damon
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um so two parts one is there a deadline
for completing the FAFSA in a given
Academic Year and then would you please
also comment
on what I believe is correct that we run
out of financial aid dollars and so
folks who fill up F so later presumably
are less likely to get financial help am
I correct on that yeah you're correct
that would be um so institutions so
what's going to happen is um students
are going to complete the form now
starting February 1st the um the FAS
that have been completed will be sent to
Institution that the students for those
students that know where they're
interested in going that information
will be sent over to those academic
institutions they'll then utilize that
to determine what grants federal
financial aid are available to those
students so there's definitely a benefit
to getting started in that with that
process earlier because individual
institutions at some point do run out of
the additional Financial Resources to
provide for those types of
Grants yeah
so just to clarify if you were that
student that you referenced a few
minutes ago who wasn't focused on
College and then late in their senior
year became interested perhaps in
applying to the local Community College
they could fill out the fafs of then but
they would be much less likely to get
eight I think it depends on the
institution and what their resources are
available to thank you that may be a
better question for this um New
Hampshire school financial aid
administrators probably answer that
question thank you very much for your
testimony thank
you uh and we have one one more person
to testify I believe uh rousan
Chester I believe you indicated one
minute I just wanted to speak a little
bit with regards to um overreach and
privacy concerns not all students have
know their parents financials situation
not all parents want their children even
as Juniors and seniors in high schools
to have that information disclosed the
fact that the IRS is going to be
providing information to the schools um
to the counselors things like that
that's
concerning um I think what's really
important in light of everything that's
going on right now the least amount of
responsib that our state
legislators needs to have the the least
amount of of oversight the the less
amount liability involved because the
bottom line here is you have kids that
are in DHHS custody
and the counselors may not know that but
the bottom line is is that they're not
going to be able to get their parents
financial information the only other
point is all of the community colleges
everyone that I've ever worked with they
do out Outreach in the schools if
they're allowed to so there's absolutely
no reason for this to be going on in the
high schools when we can have Community
College sometimes even sometimes even
universities come in present give them
the the the information they need let's
get it out of the out of the counselors
and the people that are working with our
children's in the school because there's
a huge potential for privacy violations
as well as potential for this principal
refused my son to graduate but that
principal allowed that guy to graduate I
don't think our state legislators want
to be involved in that kind of
litigation and I'm more than willing to
take any com any uh comments or
questions thank you and you were close
to that one minute um any
questions I seen none thank you very
much and uh that will close the hearing
on House Bill
1066 and we'll move directly into house
bill
1471 declaring the total solar eclipse a
school
holiday and um do we have any cards
Arlene do we have any cards for that uh
no I see I
think um yeah
Che
um we'll wait a minute for the prime
sponsored to
return
[Music]
St
representative
read
this is uh house bill for
1471 declaring the tot in total solar
eclipse a school holiday thank you very
much for uh being
here thank you Mr acting chair um I was
told in the hall as I was running back
um that a member is also having a short
bio break right now so I told her I
would go
slowly um so some of you may remember me
talking in the past about eclipses and
whatnot I have already outed myself as a
a bit of a Astro geek um in the past but
for those of you who don't know I am I'm
a member of the New Hampshire
Astronomical Society and um we're going
to have a total solar eclipse which is
super duper exciting it's different from
probably the vast majority of eclipses
you've maybe lived through where it's
like oh maybe the light looked weird for
a minute or something or you did like a
pinhole camera um a total solar eclipse
is a totally totally different if you're
in the path of totality totally
different experience it uh historically
it's it's ended Wars that's how powerful
it is um so because it's so rare the
last one that had the path of totality
through New Hampshire was
1956 the next one will be
2079 um so in 2020 I put forward a bill
I wanted to actually do something about
the schools then but it ended up being a
declaration to make the day of the total
solar eclipse April 8th of this year a
holiday had lots of very poetic language
in it and 2020 being what 2020 was uh it
didn't get through it got tabled with
like something like 700 bills in the
Senate so it was put back in the
following year and signed into law by
the governor but that bill didn't do
anything about the original problem that
I wanted to address which is in the path
of totality the moment of totality will
be at 3:30 p.m. which is right around
the time the kids are getting out of
school and right around the time parents
are picking kids up from from school or
after school activities also as any uh
member of the New Hampshire Astronomical
Society will tell you because many of
them Eclipse Chase all over the country
and some of them Eclipse Chase all over
the world traffic will be horrendous
absolutely horrendous anywhere that
there's a total solar eclipse the path
of totality traffic gets worse than than
any concert or sporting event you've
ever seen like four six even eight hour
delays and where the path of totality is
in our state is in Coos County where we
don't have the infrastructure to handle
the traffic that will be coming in so
because of that I had originally wanted
in that original uh declaration to to
actually declare a holiday for
schools um that bill having passed and
being signed into law but not addressing
the major problem I went to the
commissioner back
in September I believe and asked him
could he do anything administratively
about this oncoming kind of Crisis as I
saw it and he when I explained the
situation to him to my great surprise
was very enthused to do something about
this very excited to do something about
this but he told me he didn't have the
authority to actually do the ru making
that he needed to do so he very much
encouraged me to put in this bill and uh
said that he would give it its full
support because we are operating in the
same year as the eclipse and the eclipse
is going to be April 8th the sun waits
for no one I've asked with the help of
the commissioner for this bill to be
fast-tracked so going into the details
of what the bill actually does so most
of it is just an encouragement it allows
for flexibility for schools to do um a
half day early release remote learning
that day or have in school uh viewing
activities and other education so it
gives schools real flexibility and
doesn't mandate anything the only things
that it actually does is say that on the
day of the to solar eclipse there won't
be mandatory attendance and any child
traveling to view the solar eclipse will
rece receive an excused absence um the
other thing that it does is it gives the
department rulemaking Authority
regarding this matter so um like I said
as I understand it um I do know that the
commissioner has officially asked both
the chairs of the house and the Senate
committees to FasTrack this bill and
support it um as I understand it that's
what's being done and why I'm here on
the first day of committee um and so I
would also along those lines uh humbly
ask if you all support this to execute
as quickly as possible so with that I'm
happy to take questions thank you any
questions for the prime sponsor uh yes
representative Hall thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question so is
the the primary reason for safety you
know traffic and kids are going to be
looking at the sun from the bus and
whatever or is it more interest in
science so for me personally but I don't
know that I would have put a bill in
just for this personal reason my
interest is in science in teaching the
kids what's going on and to that ex to
that effect my organization New
Hampshire Astronomical Society has
offered to provide doe with um example
uh like curricula for the different
grade levels um for for studying this
phenomenon however the reason I think it
Rose to the level that I felt the need
to go the commissioner and say can you
do something
is because the traffic will be so bad at
the same exact time and and the the
darkness happening at the same exact
time as the kids will be either in like
going into after school activities or
waiting for their parents to pick them
up like it will be a mess for all of
that to be happening at once especially
in the path of totality so because of
that that's why I felt it needed to kind
of be
addressed representative
lakas listening to that I forgot my
question asked oh I know what it was
rule making do we actually need rule
making because that takes time and if we
want it to go
through quickly what kind of rule making
do we actually need so the the language
that is before you is the language that
I received from the commissioner and his
advisers that helped him with this
language so I just put in what they
requested um I don't know how quickly
they can can do that I do know as an
aside as part of that same conversation
with the commissioner that he's planning
on purchasing 60,000 solar eclipse
classes for every student in the state
that's cool thank
you um yes representative
Woodcock thank thank you Mr chair good
afternoon and I can see you perfect
right now it's perfect um this singular
one day event that happens typically
after school hours it's 3:30 right uh
two questions I made how long does that
actually last about three minutes um so
the second
part me oh thank yeah followup that's
exactly I ask thank you um thank you the
second the second part of this the
followup part was
then parents so the time travel it's
going to be the time travel best
locations they could find parents have
the right to dismiss their youngster or
excuse this youngster from a day I
particular like the fact that the
associations can provide curricular
through the schools uh can make it a
huge day in science in New Hampshire um
so I but I have a high time
understanding why we need to pass a law
that is going to do this when parents
can already do that the local school
committees can already do that so the
commissioner felt very strongly and I
wasn't intending on having this bill
until the commissioner encouraged me
that we needed a bill to to give them
the ability to do this administratively
there may be districts I don't I can't
speak for every district there may be
districts that kind of aren't planning
for this aren't preparing for this
appropriately the problem is the moment
of totality when everybody will be
looking up and shortly before and after
um when it's very dangerous to look up
without the proper eyewear um will be
happening right at the time where
students may not have either a teacher
to help direct them and teach them what
they're seeing and teach them how to do
it safely or their parents because it's
in that kind of ambiguous time where
they may be after school activities or
they may be in transit and at the same
time parents May be caught in the
atrocious traffic that will exist at the
same time so they may be kind of the
students might be kind of left kind of
in the Lurch in that exact moment where
they need the guidance so that's that's
why I think the commissioner and I both
felt it needed to be
addressed just one more but school thank
you the last one the school is school
under this process would not be out for
the day because be having school
activities teacher activities based on
this options for that so I go I guess to
go back to my original piece and
particular if the commissioner is going
to to fund uh everyone having glasses I
hope for representes as well um
that that at least on that particular
day parents just dismiss their
youngsters and don't doesn't require a
law so it's a local option it's app
parent he can say it's it's still a
local option and the bill it's even a
local option but for the rul making
Authority or for the ability for the
Department to handle it administratively
whether that's official Ru making or not
the commissioner felt very strongly he
needed this bill so that's why it's here
is because the commissioner requested it
um that's a good reason thank you
appreciate it representative are you
suggesting we need the day off as well I
I will add to that that uh I have in the
past possibly I'm not sure if it was
before you were in office I have passed
out uh glasses eclipse glasses to
members of the House Representative
cascaden thank thank you um so coming
from Coos County this has been a
conversation uh for quite a long time
and I don't know if you're aware several
schools in New Hampshire have planned
their Spring Breaks during that week and
of course all of Coos school districts
are closed for the day so I guess I
wonder how many school districts would
this apply to and why wouldn't it just
be a written excuse that they're going
because totality is in the North Country
some people have never been there so
even for school districts that are not
in the path of totality we want to allow
those kids to travel either to Coos or
anywhere else in the country for that
matter um for example in Texas it's kind
of the Prime viewing location because
they're almost guaranteed sunny skies on
that day and um their moment of totality
is the longest so we want to allow those
students flexibility to travel to to
view um a total solar eclipse but also
even in the other school districts that
are not in the path of totality even if
students just step out into their own
backyard they will be able to see a very
um a very full partial eclipse it's not
the same as a total solar eclipse you
don't get that moment of complete
darkness where everything just goes to
midnight like someone turned off the
lights but it is still impressive to see
through your glasses
nonetheless representative Hall thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question um so if a school district says
you know what we'll give you we're going
to take a holiday this tells me I can
take a holiday does that count as part
of one the 180 days or do they have to
find another day to make up for that day
because challenges are set so right it's
up to them and so if they want to count
that as as you've described then that
would also be up to them I think this
there's nothing in this bill that
requires that but I do know once again
that the commissioner has asked for
authority over that so perhaps that's
one of the reasons he wanted to to have
that Authority so the commissioner is
saying 100 sorry followup so the
commissioner is saying 179 days is fine
if you do this I have
not had that specific conversation with
them okay thank you uh I just had one
question um I have on occasion driven
from Manchester to
Conway um and it really didn't take me
two days so I'm just wondering why the
need for two days of excused absences no
so it's a fair point but I I did just
bring up the fact that actually in as
far as this country goes Texas is the
prime viewing location but there are
many other states in the path of
totality that may be better viewing so
if the parents are planning on taking
their students to go see a total solar
eclipse in a better viewing location um
that's one of the reasons however I will
say even among and you will hear
testimony to exactly what the conditions
are for people who chase solar eclipse
um no one is actually suggesting that
someone try to drive up to Coos even
from Southern New Hampshire and drive
back down on the same day the traffic
won't allow for
it take prob commissioner might be
buying suass not but not airplane
tickets
correct correct in fact many of the uh
hotel rooms are in the path of totality
across the entire country are already
booked it will be very
difficult uh additional questions
representative Tanner thank you thank
you for taking my question when you said
that the commissioner thought uh felt
very strongly about um he needed to
authorize or adopt these rules uh the ru
making provision in the bottom and you
said you thought is it is it just for
that one day or do you know specifically
what he wants because it seems to me
that the commissioner of Education has
the
ability um to do this without a change
in the ru making um and one of the
concerns was whether people could call
off school because of covid of a lot of
people being absent from covid and that
that was a something that went back and
forth but the commissioner felt he had
um free reign over that and so I'm
wondering if if you can explain a little
bit more about the ru making sure I I
actually thought it was under the
commissioner's purview myself but he
assured me it was not now I do not want
to conflate this solar eclipse issue
which should be completely nonpartisan
with any other issue that may be
partisan in nature or partisan appearing
so I don't want to to weigh in on what
the commissioner has done otherwise or
or anything else I'm sure that everybody
would would not be surprised that the
commissioner and I have uh difference of
views on a number of topics but where
this is concerned because I care about
astronomy and I care about science and I
care about our students having access to
it I want to make sure that that
students have the maximum ability to um
understand the value the rareness of the
event of a total solar eclipse and
appreciate it for what it
is as a followup at some point could uh
um attorney Fenton come and just uh
clarify some of that for
me after this show
oh but to the one piece of the question
I didn't answer was that it is very
limited to the the total solar eclipse
and not any other in in the bill the
rule making authori is only for the
total solar eclipse so just the one
day so thank thank you very much Mr
chair thank you very much representative
Reed um so I I too I'm concerned about
the rule making element and so I'm I'm
I'm wondering in your uh in your opinion
would uh would section sections one and
two I mean like section one sort of lays
out the the context in section two be
sufficient in
statute to um to provide what you would
like to have
done one
second section two you said yeah section
two is the compulsory attendance wave
would that alone be enough well well all
of section
two it it would would would that be
enough in statute to accomplish what you
would like to see without Ru rule
making and the reason I lay it out is
for example to representative Tanner's
question um on lines lines 12 and 13
viewing events immediately before during
and after the moment so it so there is a
uh yeah there I think the way I
envisioned uh initially this bill being
was essentially section two
um section three is at the request of
the commissioner and I figured that he
may need as he said additional R making
Authority but um if the committee sees
fit to strike that then that I think
that section two addresses my particular
concerns okay great thank you very much
any further questions see none thank you
very much
representative uh next we have uh Brian
Conley from SAU 103
good afternoon and thank you for having
me here
today um I am um a principal and
superintendent for se3 the Jenny D Blake
Elementary School in Hill I'm also uh
here to speak on behalf of the uh New
Hampshire school administrators
Association which I am part of as is U
Dr mlan and back um I am in my eth year
in in hill but I'm a former earth
science teacher so I taught astronomy um
and I too have a love of Science and I
try to impart that on anybody and
everyone who uh will listen and I did
Chase an eclipse down to Nashville back
in 2017 and I will tell you it is an
extraordinary event it is one of those
events that if you happen to be in that
3 minutes of totality and you see the
darkness fall upon you and the Stars
illuminate and the the the Birds Go
quiet it's extraordinary um so it's one
of those moments I'm hoping that we can
bring to every household in the state of
New Hampshire um not only here but
really around the the world it would be
my wish um currently I'm working with
the New Hampshire uh Aston Astronomical
Society the um uh Shephard Mall Mcall
Shepard Discovery Center the Fairbanks
Museum New Hampshire Public Radio
Vermont Public Radio U hopefully
massachus or Maine public radio to
coordinate efforts to make sure that we
can get a live stream into every school
in the state and if not into every home
um to share this moment uh I I can't
tell
you short of being in in witnessing one
of these things how important it is to
engage Our Youth and our our communities
really around Science and Technology and
Engineering and math this is a great
opportunity for us to uh build on that
um so I I do hope that we we could pass
this and and and and get it done for for
all of our kids we
are working feverishly I'm working uh
with the curriculum in instruction and
assessment people throughout the state
of New Hampshire because I I believe in
this and I I think it's very very
important thank you for for being here
any questions uh representative
dry thank you Mr chairman thank you for
your um your input so I have a question
is this is at the end of the school day
yes and the idea is to make it a an
educational experience yes so is that
educational experience supposed to
extend beyond the school hours so that's
a great question and and really the the
Crux of this the the comp the compulsory
attendance piece is to provide
like the North Country U like represent
cascaden has mentioned the schools are
already closed for in the North Country
it gives the ability for uh
superintendents uh throughout the state
of New Hampshire to determine what's
best for their Community regardless of
where you are in New Hampshire 95% of
totality will will be here so 95% of the
sun surface will be covered so
regardless of the time it's important to
train the kids or to teach the kids the
the lessons to watch safely but what is
happening so for schools that get out
you know I know some schools get out at
3:30 that kind of puts a jam on things
we can now extend the day if we wish we
can shorten the day if we wish we can
cancel the day if we wish but it's
really based around the science of of
the eclipse not just oh let's just not
have a day none of us want just not to
have another day we all want to be there
but we want to be able to have provide
the opportunity for the local districts
to make those decisions okay going
follow up okay so I'm just trying to
imagine there's probably not a case then
for like a hybrid that those who want to
stay home and and observe it at home
could but the school would still have to
run its bus schedule and Etc if they
were open is that correct yes okay I
yeah I I don't know getting into the the
and let me clarify your your question if
I may when you say hybrid meaning like a
remote option I think more I was
thinking more if it was remained a
school day but you were able to opt out
and not coming that day it would school
would still have to operate the same way
and that would still involve the problem
of buses and leaving at the same time
okay thank you f questions
representative Hall thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question so
what happens if it's a cloudy day just
curious it's a sad day is what that
is yeah no I I I I totally understand um
and I suppose you could put in place for
that like I know I could because we're
so small I could say you know what if
it's cloudy we're still we're in school
if we're not we're out of school um but
that's a that's a fair question I I I
don't know how to circumvent that but
followup oh so what do you see nothing
I'm just curious excuse me if it's a
cloudy day do you doesn't so as I uh
well you you wouldn't if if you're in
the path of totality it would go dark uh
if you're not then it would just be a
funky
I don't know I've never been a shady one
yeah funky shade of gray okay all right
thank
you
f thank
okay I'm sure uh someone might want to
look at it afterwards am I allowed to
pass these
out um you can just leave them at the
end and they'll pass them
down thank
you
so thank you chairman uh Representatives
representative Reed for uh helping push
this through uh my name is Rick Ys I'm
the founder of the New Hampshire solar
eclipse task force I'm an asset partner
solar eclipse Ambassador I am a starnet
seal uh partner solar expert and I'm the
founder and chief pilot of the eclipse
mobile here in New Hampshire
so good afternoon in the words of my
colleague Dr Kate Russo a solar eclipse
h a solar eclipse happens above you
around you and within you I suggest
adding just one word a solar eclipse
happens with awe above you a around you
and awe within
you above you day turns into night
bright stars and planets appear in the
midday sky and the moon can best be
described as a giant hole in the sky or
the eye of God long ago this event
created mostly fear but my modern
experience of three solar eclipses is
mostly awe I also find it fascinating
that a simple Shadow albeit the biggest
one I'll ever
see can create so much awe around you
awe appears as You observe the animals
people and Landscape in the distance
animals often go quiet with the sudden
arrival of night the temperature
noticeably drops and the most common
reaction among people is oh my gosh this
sentiment is usually repeated over and
over and over and over and over again I
have also observed people get very
emotional to the point of tears at the
sight of a solar eclipse even
professional astronomers are not immune
to the awe it's strongly recommended
that professionals not take pictures or
conduct any experiments when viewing a
total solar eclipse for the first time
since they are often overwhelmed and
forget to take a picture or collect data
awe is present in the distant landscape
because while it is night above and
around you it is still daylight in the
distance not under the shadow finally
for myself much of my awe has occurred
within I will probably never make it to
the moon or into orbital space at least
in this life however I imagine my solar
eclipse viewing has created similar
feelings and transformations in myself
that those few lucky astronauts
experience when they travel off planet
for myself I can only describe the awe
as being Fully Alive and connected to
the universe as an added bonus I get to
share my inner awe with everyone I meet
and invite them to join me in the shadow
having awe within is is quite nice
sharing that Ina with others is
priceless so I have been working on this
event for the past nine years after I
saw the one uh in August of 2021 in
Casper Wyoming and realized that this
one I didn't have to chase this one was
coming to us so I hooked up with Senator
Woodburn Senator star Senator Hennessy
representative Reed the
nhas whoever I could and because of
covid the bill that Governor cunu signed
into law in August of 2021 was actually
late we still don't have a a solar
eclipse scratch ticket we there's a lot
of things we don't have however we do
have the opportunity with this bill to
get the youngest in our state excited
about for them it's going to be a twice
in a-lifetime event cuz for all the 10
15 year old students in school they get
to see this with these glasses I passed
out they get to travel and throughout
New Hampshire it's 95% in Salem 96 in
Manchester 97 in lonia 98 in Plymouth 99
brenon Woods Bartlett heart's location
and the jackpot above Lancaster and
milin is 100% I will be in Pittsburgh
with a team of 30 to 60 Folks up there
uh buch of things I want to address it
is a 3 minute totality event but the
whole event is 3 hours the moon starts
covering the Sun at 2: in the afternoon
with your glasses you can see it so from
2:00 to 3:30 more and more of the sun
gets covered and then at 3:30 you have
totality then it's another hour and 20
minute Sunrise as the moon moves off the
Sun so while the main event is 3 minutes
the whole event is 3 hours uh weather
concerns we are working with the BVI
community the blind visually impaired
Community Randy Pierce at future in
sight because if we lose the weather
lotto and it is cloudy or rainy or a
snowstorm how cool would it be to turn
over the mcing of this sight of a
lifetime for most of us into an event of
a lifetime for all of us and here the
BVI community gets to lead us in event
that they rarely if they'll ever see and
we get to all experience it nonvisually
NASA has sonification devices that
transfer light into sound they have
tactile devices they have music Dr
Robert Kramer I think he's written a
couple of songs that we have we have
Rumble apps we have a huge variety so
I'm hoping for Clear Skies but if we
don't get clear skies we'll experience
it
nonvisually um we got the bill through
what else uh working with uh the kids
it's huge because we have a solar
eclipse Time Capsule the solar eclipse
Time Capsule goes into the ground
hopefully at the McCulla Shepard
Discovery Center if not it'll be at my
Domino's pizza shop here in conquer so
we have a backup location for that too
goes into the ground on May 1st
20124 55 years later the date of the
next total solar eclipse in 2079 is the
DAT it comes out of the ground I'm not
going to make 119 but the kids will and
what's even better is they can't have
any Mount gay Eclipse rum when it goes
into the Time Capsule however when it
comes out 55 years later if they led a
reasonable life they're first in line to
have a shot or at that age maybe half a
shot of M Eclipse run so I could talk
about eclipses for months but I think
I've used up most of my five minutes so
I'm happy to take any questions thank
you very much any uh
questions uh represent of Woodcock yeah
you put me on all listening here um two
questions does the uh these particular
types of lenses that that I think talked
about uh they going to be distributed
perhaps by the commissioner to all
youngsters in the school system are
there any other uh optical devices that
the average person going to be able to
access uh during that time it you'd have
to Define average because you can use
well some like you walk on the street
and I know it's coming tomorrow no no
the store no well what happened in 2017
that was really bad I like to compare it
to solar eclipse glasses are like the
opposite of a covid vaccine when the
vaccines first came out it was difficult
to get them um everybody wanted them or
a lot of people wanted them not
everybody and if you could find them you
might have to travel or spend a lot of
money to get them okay these glasses are
the reverse uh a year ago they were
everywhere they were super cheap nobody
wanted as it gets closer and closer the
availability goes down cuz you can't
print off 500 to 800 million of these
because we need them across the US they
need them across Canada and they need
them across Mexico that's a lot of pairs
of glasses and there aren't that many
companies that do it back in 2017 people
that couldn't find them or didn't want
to pay the high price they started going
to Amazon eBay the internet some of
those classes came from China okay know
I got it figured it out thank you get
your hand thank you anything further
just one more follow thank you have you
had a chance to talk with the any of the
professional associations I know we had
representative from the superintendent
but the the uh aft the Nea the the uh
the school secondary Association in
terms of how this may actually work or
could work I'm I'm thinking about Union
contract I'm thinking about paid days
I'm thinking about half days I'm
thinking about average daily tenants re
federal government has any of that stuff
through the commissioner been thought
through you know I'd have to refer you
to Ellen um way above my pay grade I
work with NASA and theas the American
Astronomical Society and hopefully the
international astronomy Union everything
I'm doing I want to take globally after
2024 because it's going to be a while
before it comes back to us thank you
appreciate that thank you thank you
anyone else questions uh seen none thank
you very much for being here appreciate
it uh last C I have is for David
McDonald so let it be known that on my
sweatshirt this is a photo of the total
solar the advisor for Belmont High
School astronomy club in Belmont New
Hampshire thank you for allowing me to
to share a little
bit as I walk into into the room what's
the first thing I noticed picture of
Christa
mlli and you know what Christ mlli was
known as the field trip teacher she was
known as the field trip teacher I was 10
years the education director at the
Mccalla Shepard Discovery Center I still
work there now part-time as a senior
educator I'm full-time stem teacher
astronomy teacher at belon high school
now I have taught astronomy for Grant
State College nhti Lakes Region
Community College and blou State
graduate
school and I am a a director for the New
Hampshire Astronomical Society I am vice
president of the New Hampshire solar
eclipse task force and I love eclipses I
love education I love the passion that
uh science can get kids excited about
things that other things can't who wants
to read Walden P I'm kidding I went to
Walden par it's a great place I've taken
field trips there with kids but what an
opportunity because as already said the
next opportunity 55 years down the road
for here in New Hampshire I traveled
myself 20 hours to uh Hopkinsville
Kentucky in 2017 August 21st for 2
minutes and 45 seconds of
totality
lifechanging you know what else was
lifechanging it's it's time to leave
it's time to head back to New Hampshire
I drive 5 miles west to an interstate
four lanes going north four Interstate
Lanes all going north nobody's moving I
did a UI don't tell anybody I did a UI
on the ramp I'm not getting in that M
and I drove 25 miles east to another
Interstate four lanes going north and
nobody's moving we went to a general
store and got a map and went home run
back roads and we got there probably
before the other people did it's an
amazing thing and so as I already
pointed out you can't travel to the
eclipse on Monday the 8th because the
traffic is going to be so bottled up and
as I shared we got four lanes here four
lanes here but don't worry we have route
three right we have Route
16 nobody's going anywhere on the eth so
that's why we encourage a day to like
they can go up on the Saturday go up on
the Sunday uh I'm going up Friday night
uh and then a travel day to get back on
Tuesday so the question a question that
I heard is well parents can just write a
note and excuse them but listen people
you know what you have the opportunity
to do you people have the opportunity to
highlight boldface
italics Big
Font the importance of this because yeah
they can parents can write an excuse any
day to get out any day in Belmont they
can excuse three days and after that
they get in
trouble but if it's a bill it's like
this is like legit like this is a big
deal and you people have the opportunity
to encourage students and to encourage
families to go up to doesn't have to be
into New Hampshire they can go to
Buffalo New York Cincinnati Ohio up in
Maine go up to
Montreal but wherever they go for
totality that they get credit for the
day and with uh you know recommended a
day for travel on the
Tuesday and I I just encourage you to uh
to
endorse pass this bill for the
children it's a big deal and you people
have the opportunity to heighten the
importance of this big deal though yeah
maybe the results could be handled
without a bill
maybe but this just underscores the
importance of a once in a-lifetime
opportunity for many of the kids some
kids may get the chance to do it twice
but for New Hampshire 55 years is the
next one and so Christa the field trip
teacher let's encourage this field trip
and I appreciate the time that you've
given me to chat with you a little bit
thank you very much uh any questions
uh seeing none thank you very much for
being here and your present my pleasure
thank you um with
that okay is attorney Fenton still
here would you um have any information
for us on the rul making uh provision in
this
legislation
good afternoon good
afternoon for the record my name is
Diana Fenton I'm an attorney with the
Department of Education and I'm very
thankful for the previous speakers
because um I know nothing about solar
eclipses and I'm back there taking notes
and you guys got me all jazzed up and
now I'm going to take my kids out of
school to go see it so uh I I appre
thank thank you um and want those
glasses on a t-shirt but that's probably
overstepping just a bit um but as you
know we do not support or oppose bills
but I am here to answer technical
questions and I think there are some
questions about the rul making um so
representative Tanner if you'd like to
ask me the direct question so I am not
presumptuous which get me in trouble so
my first question is um does this apply
this authorization to adopt rules
um just for the solar
eclipse so thank you for the
question it it it does the short answer
is it does I think to further um address
your concern I would refer you to other
Provisions in the law that really
enumerate what this legislative body
wants the department to do for ruem I
think seeing this language here this
looks broad to me I will refer you to
RSA 126 u8 just as an example there are
other provisions of the law but if you
look at restraint and seclusion for
example again 126 u8 it says the State
Board of educ Education shall adopt
rules pursuant to Ru making Authority
relative to and then it
enumerates a b c you know it enumerates
exactly what it wants the department to
do rule making
for more guidance is always helpful as
someone who who's engaged in rule making
quite a bit the more guidance and
direction this legislative body can give
to the department as to what you want
the rules to
Encompass is is helpful to the
department also rule making Authority
belongs to the state board it is not a
commissioner Authority it is not a
department Authority it is a state board
authority I hope I've answered your
question um follow up yes if I can um so
I guess the other thing is that if
schools can call off for snow days and
schools can call off for covid or that
the commissioner the or whoever down at
this Department of Education decides
whether schools can cancel because of
low attendance because of covid or not
um without Ru making why I I understand
the need for the or not the need but why
we would like the other part to really
highlight this event like everybody's
jazzed this all up now like you said
yeah I'm tot I'm glad I've got the
glasses right um uh but you know I'm
just concerned of why that's added and
and um why it's necessary at this point
um as far as schools is it so so if a
school wanted to call it off they could
if they wanted to have a half day they
could uh isn't that true at this point
without this Ru
making I appreciate the question I I
don't know if comparing this to to covid
is an appropriate comparison simply
because that was a public health
emergency and so I would be hesitant to
look at that instance and compare it
with this simply because there were
other issues at play I.E the public
health emergency that are not part of
this I think that what you are hearing
from the people who testify and what you
are hearing from the field is that the
field wants the support of the
department in making this decision and I
can tell you in other areas you know I
have heard that across the board where
the field looks to the department for
their you know approval and I use that
word Loosely um and just their support
in making this in making these decisions
and I I think that's the subtext of this
bill and I think that's been what I've
heard in this testimony
um you know in in terms of your question
as couldn't they already do this I think
they could I say that as a bit of a
caveat I'd have to look into a little
bit more but I I think that they could
I.E I will refer you to my previous
testimony is I'm planning to take my
children out of school uh so there's
that um you'll see if you see me here on
April 8th but
um I again I think this is more of just
looking for that support from the
Department um we all know at this
committee the more that the local
districts and the department can be
working
together is helpful to all of us so
again I will I'm happy to get back to
you on your question I think that um any
concerns about the rul making can easily
be
addressed by just adding in some clarity
as to what this legislative body wants
those rules to
Encompass thank you any further
questions uh representative lakus
please yes I'm just looking at the time
thing and wondering how long it takes to
to do this Ru making when this is a
fast-paced Bill thank you for the
question and you're absolutely correct
uh rule making anyone who's familiar
with the process knows that it it takes
a long time um I call it a legislative
tennis match because there's a lot of
back and forth and it never seems to end
right so and I like tennis but
um there are ways to get rules in front
and moving quickly I.E emergency rul
making they're there're different little
mechanisms that we could work with I do
want to reach out to OS to make sure
that this would fall within one of those
um exceptions to the rule I know
emergency rule making is is limited it
really is emergency Ru making for
certain purposes so I need to check with
that and I'm happy to do that and get
back to this committee to see if that
would fit within those parameters great
thank you that would be appreciated of
course um see no further questions thank
you very much for uh getting
jazzed Mr chair Mr chair before you
adjourn this is it possible to have the
the general cour clerk answer questions
since he's here for his professional
opinion uh related to this bill the
legislation
um I I why don't you talk to the clerk
afterwards we were're kind of late for
public it's because it's public
information it's a process Bill a
process question would would you like to
entertain a question Mr
clerk thank you appreciate that I can
see you're excited about it um my my
question deals with uh timing in in your
opinion knowing how bills if this was
fast-tracked and passed and passed is it
possible to have this approved and
signed in time for an April deadline yes
thank you thank you Mr chair uh thank
you Mr Clerk
with with that I will again uh end U the
hearing on uh House Bill uh
um and we'll um switch clerks and
proceed to House Bill
1206 relative to prohibiting educator
indoctrination um and I would just uh
point out um to the prime sponsor that
we'll need a car from you when you're
finished um and also that this is a
hearing um it's not an exec session so
it's not a debate it's just a
hearing so with that um I call on the
prime sponsor representative
lakas hello and thank you for
considering my bill Alicia leas Hills
burial 38 which is Hudson and
Lichfield
um for a very long time we have been
told that it's very important to
understand intentive bills and things
like that because it is
used in court cases Etc to understand
what was actually meant so to try to
avoid um misunderstanding I'm going to
uh try to cover whatever questions I can
think of and make sure people understand
what this bill is about and um what
might be considered indoctrination spend
for one minute um would someone be
willing to close the doors there um
little noise in the
hallway thank you please uh proceed
representative so I worked on this
language for a long time because I
wanted to get it as clear as possible
and to make it
as to make it to be understood by any
random person as much as possible I talk
to a lot of people I talk to an English
Professor a
lawyer um working and and many many
other people many legislators many
friends trying to figure out how to make
this as clear as possible and I will go
through it
um to try to help keep it from being
misunderstood now I know that people can
misunderstand anything including
intentional
misunderstanding just look at any Genie
who's granting
wishes and in case you're wondering yes
that's a fictional
reference
um so I'm going to go line by line
Educators shall not present unproved
theories as fact so it's not a matter of
not presenting theories or any theories
being banned or anything it's just how
they're presented are they presented as
a theory or is they presented as a fact
2 + 2 = 4 that's a fact nothing can
travel faster than the speed of light
that's a theory now there's a lot of
evidence for it but we still don't know
it it hasn't been proved and maybe
there's beginning to be some evidence
that some particles might go faster than
the speed of light or maybe they go
backwards and
time we're not really sure but at any
rate that's a theory and so a lot of
times what we hear and see people
objecting to is when um theories are
presented as fact and H how can you tell
well first off it's very difficult to
prove something is true it's very diff
it's very easy to prove that it's not
you only need one counter example and
know it's not true but to prove that it
is true that can take well we still have
things that we can't prove or true that
most people kind of believe are true but
we can't prove it so it always has to be
couched in terms of a theory think about
Galileo right think about for how long
we believe the Earth was the center of
the solar system and what a big deal
that
was
[Music]
um so we have to be
careful and an example that we were
taught when I was in school was Neil's
bore and his indivisible Adam and the
Adam was the smallest that anything
could be divided into any matter could
be divided into and we were taught that
not because it was still believed but so
that we could understand how ideas
change and that we wouldn't just assume
something was true that we would
understand that well this is our best
understanding at the moment but that
will change that will change in my years
of studying physics I've certainly
learned a lot of things that were very
different than when I was first taught
and that was why we were taught about
Neil's bore and the indivisible atom um
which would now we know there's lots of
particles
right so we have have to be careful as
teachers that we pass on
that skepticism that okay this is what
we believe
today but that doesn't mean it's true
it's a
theory
um as part of that I just want to talk
about modeling because some of the new
science uses modeling and you also
can't conflate the two modeling can give
you it's a tool to help you make
predictions but if a model says
something it doesn't make it a fact and
so when you you can use it to help you
make predictions right up until the
prediction doesn't hold and then you
know oh my model isn't quite right let's
go back and fix it I've developed
models um and that was always open was
how we can easily change that model to
to represent what's happened and so
anytime you have a model that doesn't
always hold true it's not a true model
so it's you you can't say well the model
predicts this
therefore this is what's going to happen
no the model predicts this therefore
well there's a pretty good chance we
hope if we did our model right and so
you can't do that teach that as fact
either you have to teach it as a good
guess
um
another
way if you're asking yourself is if
you're a teacher is this fact or is this
a
theory another a sort of a a guide poost
that you can use is if there are other
people who believe differently it's
probably a
theory and so rather than teaching it as
this is the truth you teach it as this
is one Theory and then there are people
out there who believe another theory
the just like in Galileo's time right
you had Galileo and people who followed
him who were very much opposed to the
idea that the Earth was in the center of
the solar system it's the same thing
when you start hearing those other ideas
that should be a clue to you that this
is not a fact I'm going to be teaching
this is a theory and I have to present
other theories whatever other people is
the world flat is it
round etc etc there are lots of things
today that I hear being taught as fact
that are really theories and how do you
know well you don't necessarily know but
if there's a PO portion of the
population that disagrees well they're
not just nut jobs or science deniers or
whatever you might think they are
because you think you are
right no it means they have a different
Theory than you do and you present that
[Music]
um another thing I want to talk about
then would be value statements and the
ACLU
wrote and they asked some
specific
uh questions about whether or not things
would
be all allowed so to speak
um in teaching a unit on the Holocaust
teaching that totalitarian forms of
government are wrong with that be banned
would an educator statement that
neo-nazism or racism in 2024 is wrong be
banned
um Can an educator say that the theory
there's that word theory of evolution is
correct well none of those things are
right you couldn't do that
people might think oh but those make
complete sense Hitler was a bad
man but what they have in common is they
have a value statement and certainly
when I was in English as a kid I learned
what value statements were you're
making a value judgment on that thing or
person Hitler was
bad totalitarian forms of government are
bad
once you use those words good bad once
you make value in there that's an
opinion okay it may be that most people
believe that Hitler was bad it's still
an
opinion rather than saying Hitler was
bad you show what did
Hitler do what did he say what did he do
you let the student make that
determination Hitler was good or Hitler
was bad you give the
facts Hitler did this Hitler said that
and
then for kids who were a little more
advanced maybe middle school or
certainly in high school how did he get
away with that how did the people in his
government follow along with what he was
doing how did they send all those Jews
to work camps and to gas
Chambers how did people let that happen
and that's a good discussion because
those things can happen
anywhere now or in the
future so you don't need if you give a
value judgment what happens is you close
down
communication if you leave it open and
give the facts and let kids think about
it you're actually opening up
conversation the kids aren't looking to
you to tell tell them what to think
they're beginning to think for
themselves and after all that's what
we're supposed to be doing we're
supposed to be teaching kids how to
think not what to think and as soon as
you start telling students what to think
you're shutting
down you're shutting down their own
mental
development you want to encourage you
want to open them
up to give them other ways of thinking
so you want to present information but
you want them to come to their own
conclusions and that's a lot of what
this bill is about is encouraging kids
figuring out ways of
teaching to open
up um a person's ability to think to
wonder to come to their own
conclusions when I was in school we had
no
idea what our teachers political
viewpoints were what their sexuality was
anything like that the teachers
presented us
with what
happened and let us figure out those
questions they might even ask us I mean
a good one
here
[Music]
um would a statement that communism is
an unsuccessful form of government be
banned
well rather than saying something like
that you could you you could look at the
various forms times that communism has
been instituted through history you
could assign that as a
question but first you have to say what
does unsuccessful mean what does it mean
to be successful what does it mean to
succeed what does it mean to fail
because whenever you're going for a
proof I'm a mathematician and I always
learned first thing you do is you define
your terms be and so same thing with
having a conversation Define your terms
before you even start discussing or you
can end up fighting with each other when
you really agree but you just have a
different idea what the words mean so
Define your terms send it as a uh an
assignment for them to figure out is is
it successful is it not now when does it
get to be indoctrination when you have a
set answer for that when you've decided
yourself yes it's successful no it's not
successful and you grade accordingly If
instead you grade did the student give a
good definition did he follow up his
definition did he back up whichever he
decided according to that
definition does he have a case if he
came up with
a an exception to that then it's not a
true thing because he's came he has come
up with an exception to the statement
therefore it's not
true if you grade that way that's not
indoctrination that's teaching kids to
think teaching kids to do research
teaching kids to come up with answers if
you've decided ahead of time yes it's
true no it's not true and I'm going to
grade based upon whether they say yes or
no now you're pushing your opinion and
that's indoctrination and I hope that's
clear the difference between
those
um let me see what
else oh administrators should not bring
into teacher in service training outside
sources nor require teachers to view
material from outside sources with the
intent
to push or assert advocate for otherwise
compelled belief in any particular
Theory or ideology now we've talked
about how you know it's a theory or an
ideology because you've got discrepancy
in people from one side or another right
so are you having somebody to come in to
push a particular point of
view or have you invited people from
each side to come in and
present and so that's where you get into
trouble when a school district has
decided but this is the way we want
everybody to think and they bring in
people to support that point of view and
in
fact even in the ACLU
letter
[Music]
um it talks about classroom debate being
between instructors or guest speakers
who wish to promote the merits of their
their position that's indoctrination
promote the merits of their
position if you want to do that you're
going to have to bring in people from
multiple points of view their position
and whoever is representing a different
position then you're not indoctrinating
then you're presenting side you know
presenting what the various theories are
but as soon as you start deciding one
Theory or one ideology over others then
you're indoctrinating you're not just
informing
um nothing in this section shall be
construed to prohibit discussing as part
of a larger course of academic
instruction the historical and current
existence of various theories and
ideologies and that's
important to get both historical
and current it's not it it that opens up
discussion what's going on now how does
that relate to me we had
slavery back for quite a while in our
country we still have slavery in our
country it just looks different and so
what is the historical significance of
slavery what is the current significance
of slavery how do we try to keep that
from happening in the future
that's all any of these ideologies any
of these belief
systems it's important to talk about to
to present those um what they
are and did they exist in the past do
they exist now however they look let's
see
so I would say that if any student other
than through a lucky
gas knows or can tell what a teacher's
religious or political views or sexual
orientation are the teacher has
failed and I'm very open to
questions uh thank you representive
cascaden thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question um
my concern is um title of indoctrination
gives a public perceptive P
perspective that indoctrination is going
on in public
schools but I know that all teachers are
bound to Professional Standards and the
code of ethics and I know the code of
conduct is mentioned here as well and
you mentioned that you spoke to a lot of
variety of people so my question is
twofold
have you spoken to public school
Educators and administrators are public
school
administrators uh contributing to
indoctrination and can you give a
specific example is what why this what
drives this bill okay yes I have talked
to teachers I have talked to um spouses
of
teachers and something that I hear very
often
have heard multiple times from multiple
places multiple school districts is that
the administrators are pushing specific
ideologies and telling the teachers that
they have to teach them and the teachers
don't want to but they're afraid to
speak up I can't tell you any of their
names because they're afraid of um
retribution and but it is not it is
oh I can't even tell you all the
different towns I've heard this from and
my husband has heard this from because
if I'm here he often goes out places and
he'll just set up con you know just chat
with whoever is nearby right he might go
out for lunch and sit at the bar and
chat with whoever and he'll come home
and tell me these stories that people
have talked to him about it happened
just last week in fact so that is a lot
of what drives
this that and closing and not wanting to
close down um students ability to think
for themselves representa
Tanner thank you and thank you for
taking my question can you give me a an
ex kind of go into this a little bit
deeper about this administrator that
brings in specific ideology that uh
teachers are forced to teach could you
give me an example of that because I it
it is in my realm of thought that that
happens but Dei Dei is an
ideology okay um some people very some
people super support it because they
believe it's inclusive and gets people
to be inclusive other people very much
think that it's a horrible thing it
teaches people to be
racist um I know some of my black
friends who think it's insulting the
idea that they need white people to help
them to be able to do whatever they can
do the idea that they can't do on their
own but they need these people of
privilege to help use their privilege
for them to succeed when they believe
that they're perfectly successful and
able to be successful on their own and
they get very upset by the fact that
it's being taught so there are teachers
where they have Dei Specialists come
in for teacher training and tell them
you have to incorporate at this
throughout your day whatever you're
doing so it's not curriculum so nobody
can go and ask ahead of time is this
being taught is this part of the
curriculum because it's not it's
supposed to be part of each part of the
day what the teacher is supposed to
include it whether it's math or gym or
whatever it is and the teachers are like
I don't believe in this I don't want to
teach this yes I think it's racist I
think it's harmful and I don't want to
do it and so that would be an an
example follow up sure um so you're
talking about just so I'm perfectly
clear on this tolerance for
diversity equality of
people and Justice in in that people are
under Justice or under the law as the
United States has it so those particular
values you don't think should be taught
in school that's not what I'm talking
about I'm talking about the other parts
of Dei the parts that teach that you are
absolutely racist because you're white
the part that says that you have
privilege because you're white the part
that says that you have to be an ally to
people who aren't white so they can
succeed because otherwise they can't
succeed that's
racist that's what people are objecting
to further questions uh representative
Woodcock thank you shair just a simple
one and I I apologize for being loud on
the outside missing the right Le I was
still an R from the eclipse yeah um I'm
looking at uh and if you may have
already if you already covered this just
tell me don't waste your time again uh
I'm looking at line 11 and 12 of of uh
your your bill your your bill and I'm
thinking about my years as a uh social
science teacher uh and I would this says
you can't require a student compel a
student I would often require students
to to ab ab ab all you people going to
speak and and we're debate 1 two 3 4 and
you're going to speak on this in favor
of that and you're going to speak on
this against that so that we hav't doing
the research and all things but that if
I read this correctly that I as a
teacher I would not be able to say that
you are going to you are going to you're
on side one one pick it out one you are
against slavery uh side two you are for
slavery and that you know you want to do
and that's how we start the dialogue for
instance on on a class and let make do
the research you know for appropriately
for the high squ basic debate techniques
yes so or any subject but I mean but I'm
now telling them yes that's the side
you're going to be on and this what
you're going to do so if I read this
right I I can't do that I can't compel
students to express belief of support of
any particular
you're not you're not asking them as
themselves to believe in slavery or not
believe in slavery you're asking them to
present that position in a debate
correct which is different than asking
them for their belief in that
thing well if there if there if I just I
won't get into a dialogue with you if I
may to further clarification or say in
support of which is debate or in Le or
support of so if I am on a a team of
three of us supporting or not supporting
a topic then we're going to be coming
from the position yeah we support that
this is why um so I I just that's all I
just find it from I find it particularly
as you uh get higher uh age youngsters
and the high school particularly where
kids Fredy shop and they would they have
back training and they really want to
get passionate about things and they'll
whichever way you tell them to go they
just want to debate um so I I find that
maybe kind of I find other things here
but that's particularly just so it
jumped out at me having having having
been part of a debate club that competed
inter um
nationally I see a difference between
asking them in a debate to present a
certain
side and
then the opposite side even I mean as as
a debate team you have to willing
because you don't know which side you're
going to get at any point in time you
have to be able to present both but
that's different than asking them to
believe in that actually asking that
trying to convince them that your side
is correct or your ideology is correct
to get them to believe okay I got it
thank you you got it that's okay thank
you agree with thank you uh
representative
Hall thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question so
lines 1 to
24 really I think teachers and
administrators are the bad guys they're
the ones that are doing the the
indoctrination okay so lines 25 and 26
my question is how is that going to be
enforced is that up to students and
parents to report out who's who's
enforcing 25 and 26 is my question first
off I'm not saying anybody is bad guys
and there are plenty of teachers who
teach very well without
indoctrinating okay so I don't want to
imply there that that you can't teach or
there aren't teachers that you
you that there are teachers that all
teachers indoctrinate I don't want to
apply that at all I just am trying to
make sure that where it's happening it
steps back and who is going to bring It
Forward it could be another teacher it
could be the school administrator who
happens to notice it when they're
walking past and hears what's going on
it could be the students it could be the
teachers I mean the parents who the
student has complained to it would then
be it would have to be investigated
right you're not going to just assume I
mean when when when anything else comes
up to find out whether somebody violates
the New Hampshire code of conduct
there's a whole investigation and that
would still be the whole investigation
and I would hope you would start
with if that investigation is done and
somebody has found that yes they were
indoctrinating that they would there
would be a conversation that says this
is the difference this is how you would
do this without indoctrinating as
opposed to with indoctrinating right not
Hitler is bad but these are the things
that Hitler
did thank you and and well at any rate
and if you continueed to do that that
might escalate along there can I follow
up can I just follow quickly very
quickly yeah I I wasn't suggesting that
you would think every teacher was
indoctrinating or every administrator
but when when you when clearly it said
the administrator you know they do the
does the work up who reports that so
that I I definitely didn't think you
thought every single teacher and every
administrator in this thank you uh
representative
Ford your mic
I was wondering as you were talking
about the circumstances of people who
teach in schools with religious
affiliations and the predicaments they
get in when the so-called authorities on
either side of an argument
differ uh a good example is um in the
beginning was the word and the Word was
God straight from the Bible and yet a
geology teacher says in the beginning
was the Precambrian all that stuff we
don't know about and then it began with
the oriv visan curan devonian plyo scine
that's the Ice Age and then someone says
well how do we know that happened
because we found a human being frozen in
a
glazier
fact we got one they live then well what
about before then some of that we don't
know and so you then start to say there
are different calendars don't you and
that calendars are a construct a way of
cutting time into pieces but in fact
they're virtually all arbitrary AR not
capricious but arbitrary there you're
choosing to look at time in this way or
in these Cuts or in these slps excuse me
represent do you have a question for
well the question is how does that fit
into your argument about selective
factual Etc well those it when remember
when I said if you have people with
different ideas of that it's not facts
it's ideology and so then you would
present it that way there are people who
believe that time that the world started
at this time and time was divided up
this way and Etc there are people who
believe that looking at time according
to the theory of
relativity that actually things were
moving much faster in the beginning and
that really all of that large time
period really was just one day from our
time period Etc and you would
present and allow your students to
present the different ideas
as different belief systems different
ideologies the trick is not to come down
on one
right to leave it
open thank you any further questions for
the representative representative
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my
question so I have two examples that I
would like you to comment
on one would be a civics or possibly
history teacher invites an elected
official who has a party affiliation to
be a guest speaker actually in back up
they invite all the elected officials
say all the state Reps for a particular
District to come in
its not everyone
accepts and in fact only one party is
going to be represented to
speak is that teacher expected
to not acknowledge that person's party
affiliation
to require that
speaker to Endeavor to be completely
non-partisan while presumably the point
I should have said is to share some
perspective about the way government
process
happens so that's one example and then I
would like to ask the other one okay
well I've certainly been um invited to
such classes and the teacher made a
point of of inviting both sides and
um we've done that more than once and
one time yes we were the only ones that
showed up that was not the fault of the
teacher that was for whatever reason
nobody else showed up and so when we
presented things we presented it as our
opinion not as fact but as this is what
we believe and so again the the teacher
has done her best and she can explain
that there is another side those people
weren't able to come but um she's still
trying to say there are vult multiple
sides and we presented our side as our
side not as fact did you have another
quick uh yes thank you um so when my
daughters were in high school a
philosophy teacher at the school at the
time still today um um would invite
different guest speakers to come in and
talk about their Rel religious system or
lack
thereof and one of the speakers was an
atheist um I think this teacher
particularly invited that person to
speak to make sure that these students
were aware of
that belief system or lack of belief
system
um I don't think practically speaking
that you could expect in the time frame
of our school day in the massive stuff
we expect to happen that a teacher would
be able to represent every religion so
how do you respond to that well when a
teacher is presumably the teacher was
teaching about comparative religions
right okay so the
teacher for one thing when the teacher
is done doing that the students should
not be able to guess what religion that
teacher
had okay so that that's sort of a clue
to tell you whether or not they were
successful in teach in showing things
objectively is if none of the students
could even tell after the end of
teaching all of those
things which the teacher itself her his
or herself believed then they were
successful yeah I um sorry but yes you
don't always have time to do all I know
when we did that when I was in school we
were each asked to pick a religion and
we as students presented them and that
avoided
that uh
conflict quickly please we have three
more speakers
so I guess I'd like further
clarification on how in our small rural
communities where a teacher is a person
who lives in the
community and in my last example May
attend a particular church or synagogue
that their students
attend okay the teacher may not be
talking about that in the classroom per
your um
approach but I think it's completely
unfeasible that students won't have any
idea um do you
agree yes if it's a small community
community and some of the kids go to
church with the teacher yes they're
they're going to know but it's not going
to come from what they presented in
school it's going to come from outside
any further
questions see none thank you very much
for presenting your legislation and next
we have um Meg Megan
Tuttle she had to leave okay like I can
leave our testimony that'd be great
thank you and I can uh Briefly summarize
it okay if you want to then present a
card um but um a quickly summary because
we can get copies made yes I will make
it very quick and fill out a card thank
you Mr chairman members of the committee
for the record Brian Hawkins filling in
for Megan tutle today um uh a couple of
points I just wanted to make is uh first
um we feel that uh this bill is follows
a similar formula to bills that we've
seen um in previous previous
years uh basically that the uh language
of the bill is extremely vague um and it
leaves uh educator it will leave
Educators wondering how to interpret
this uh
language um and then it is followed up
by uh a potentially very stiff
consequence for that educator which is
uh a violation of the coda conduct which
can as this committee knows can lead
to uh an educator losing uh potentially
losing their license
um the standards in the bill are as I
said vague um for for example uh the
educator shall not present unproved
theories as fact and not push or assert
or Advocate or compel students to
express belief in support for any
particular Theory or IDE ideology um so
where does this leave disc discussing
all sorts of uh scientific sociological
historical theories or ideas in class
and where is uh the line between
classroom discussion debate and the term
push or assert uh what's the standard
for an unproved Theory um this is
unclear um you know this is the type of
legislation that I think uh we heard
testimony and the teacher shortage
committee over the course of the last
couple of years and in that report they
said that uh that was issued not uh just
two months ago classroom teachers are
feeling and Reporting stress and
concerns for the consequence as a result
of the legislation proposed and passed
in our state house and leaving the
profession teachers leaving the
profession most often cite the climate
and culture as the biggest factor in
their departure from
education uh and New Hampshire
altogether and so we believe 1206 would
be an extension of that I'll close my
testimony and give the uh hand in the
written testimony very
much um yeah you can just hand it to the
gentleman at the
end also happens to be a
representative um Deborah
house
did I just turn this yes want to make
sure I turned it on not back off okay my
name is Deborah how I am president of
the American Federation teachers New
Hampshire and uh I am here on behalf of
our members to speak in opposition of
hb26 um you know I I do take the um
maker of the bill at her word that she
did not intend to imply that there is a
problem with Educators indoctrinating in
this state but certainly reading the
text of the bill and the title of the
bill it makes it sound like there's such
a problem with Educators and
administrators indoctrinating students
that you have to pass a law against it
and we've got a problem with that it is
offensive to all those people who are
working so hard every day to educate our
students uh they do this because they
care about students they want them to
learn grow and Thrive and it spills like
this as the previous speaker mentioned
that are part of what is to driving
people out of the
profession in our schools which I I
would hope that the maker of the bill
will get more informed about what goes
on in our Public Schools but in social
studies and science we do a lot with the
inquiry method where we work hard to
make sure students have access to
primary documents and learn how to do
research so they can indeed form their
own opinions we are not teaching them
what to think but we're teaching them
how to find the information so they can
draw their own conclusions we're
teaching them how to observe how to
collect data how to put things together
so that they can um piece it together
and form their own
conclusions this bill is based on
misunderstanding or misrepresentation
misrepresentation of what we do in
public schools it creates yet another
vague and IL defined standard which will
interfere in the Public School
classrooms and keep students from
getting the robust education there's
their constitutional right in New
Hampshire simply put this is another
classroom censorship Bill the effect
will be to make our Public Schools less
welcoming to all students in our
communities how do we know this we've
seen what happened after the divisive
Concepts law
passed we've seen the effect of the simp
similarly vague divisive Concepts law
which failed to Define its vague terms
and also threaten teachers and School
staff with the possible loss of license
if they violated them since that law
took effect we have also seen some
extremists insist that any recogn
recognition of students who are lgbtq or
of a family structure that consists of
two moms or two dads any such
recognition is considered gender
Ideology Now would that be considered an
ideology under this bill and would that
be something we can no longer mention or
read a story book where someone has two
moms or two
dads we don't want to see that happen in
our schools all of our kids deserve to
feel included being welcoming and kind
to all of our students and making sure
they feel welcome in our classrooms is
not an ideology it's just being Being
Human don't take the humanity out of our
public schools let us teach our kids the
bottom line is that every Granite State
student has a constitutional right to a
robust public education and the state of
New Hampshire has an obligation to its
students to provide
it putting laws like this in the way of
students being able to feel that they
are welcome and belong like they are
full members of their classroom
communities is wrong for our students
for our Public Schools for our teachers
and the school staff in the granite
state I urge you to find HB 1206 in
expedient to legislate thank
Youk uh any
questions see none thank you very
much and our last speaker this afternoon
is Mary
wiy
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee my name is Mary wilky I'm a um
retired school teacher public school
teacher and I Liv in conquered and I'm
opposed to this bill um I I don't want
to repeat what other people have said
the vagueness issue does worry me um I
think when you talk about value uh
statements um as a teacher you kind
of it's hard to avoid value statements
if a if a child in my class calls
another child the n-word do I have to
say well some people don't think that's
okay but other people do think it's okay
um I up until now I'm no longer teaching
but up until I finished teaching I said
that's not
okay um there are a number of times when
you call you know is it okay to say it's
better to share please you know please
share your materials it's better to
share our classroom materials than to
hoard them um that's a value
statement I made it many times in the
course of a day you often dealing with
interpersonal Rea interactions that
raise value issues and I guess I feel
like you if that's if that's the
guideline it's really hard to follow am
I going to have to stop and think wait
is this ideology is this not ideology
ideology has a very vague definition in
the dictionary by the way so that's one
thing but I know other people are
addressing that um I just would like to
say that as a person who devoted a good
part of my career to Public School
teaching I find it disheart that year
after year there are bills I mean this
one used to be called teachers loyalty
you know at last time it was teachers
can't teach communism and Marxism um you
know teachers that I know and I've
taught in four schools I had two
children who went to three different
schools I know many many teachers
through all those ways I've never met
one who was in the business of trying to
indoctrinate students my own experience
and my kids experience was yes teacher
were trying to teach kids how to think
for themselves give them the tools the
knowledge the research skills and let
them come to their own conclusions um
and so to have a bill education not
indoctrination and I noticed it's not
being imposed on religious schools that
by definition do indoctrinate and that's
fine that's their right although I would
prefer not to pay for it but that's what
you know here we have education not
indoctrination it is very disheartening
uh it's just disheartening to see this
year after year year I went into
teaching and so did my colleagues
because we loved to learn we wanted to
pass on that love of learning we wanted
to help kids have a bright future uh not
because we wanted to convince them that
our way of thinking is the only way of
thinking we didn't lie awake at night
scheming up plans to make them into
Communists or make them into whatever
the latest problem is I lay awake at
night thinking about the child that just
arrived from Congo where his father was
killed in War I lay awake at night
wondering how can I help this child who
hates to read what can I find for this
child that will help him enjoy reading
what can I do about this child who
doesn't like to write and what topic
might really grab her so she'd want to
write what can I do about the little
girl whose mother is dying of cancer and
she lives with her stepfather who she
doesn't get along with there there were
plenty of things for me to lie at wake
at night of about and they weren how am
I going to make my students into people
who think like me that was the last
thing on my mind and it's just you can
tell I don't usually testify in an
emotional
way it's very hard I taught for 20 years
I devoted my heart and soul to teaching
and none of it had to do with
indoctrination and this is just
insulting thank you very much for uh
Your Service uh to our children and um
your testimony today uh representative
Pell thank you Mr chair um thank you for
coming in testify that's a longer day
than we thought um you brought up
religious schools and I just want to ask
if do you think perhaps parents might
choose a religious school for the exact
purpose of having their children
indoctrinated in their ideology as
opposed to choosing a public school in
the hopes that their children would not
be indoctrinated in any specific
ideology uh yes that may well be and I
have I don't want to sound like I have
any problem with religious schools um
but if we think of teaching as something
where you're trying to help kids learn
how to think then we we want to give
them the option of of thinking of of
coming to their own conclusions and
that's what I think people do look for
in public schools and I think that's
what public school teachers uh do try to
do any further questions seeing none
thank you very much thank you and um
that uh wraps up our day um we have uh
another full day tomorrow and correct me
if I'm wrong but I believe we start at
9:15
tomorrow great thank you
everybody